Herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio beim Blue Moon bei Fritz am 29. März 2018, wo wir heute über ein Thema reden wollen, das wie immer im Chaosradio so mit der digitalen Welt zu tun hat, in der wir leben. Und manchmal muss man bei einem Chaosradio lange nachdenken. Was machen wir denn in diesem Monat? Diesen Monat lag es klar auf der Hand. Belöschen Facebook. So heißt zumindest der Hashtag, der durch die sozialen Netzwerke auch so ein bisschen rumgereicht wurde. Delayed Facebook. Und da ging es natürlich um diesen Skandal mit Cambridge Analytica und persönlichen Daten, die ausgewertet wurden. Und viele User, die ausspioniert wurden. Und die Frage, die sich dann stellt, was ist genau passiert? Was bedeutet das für uns? Kann man Facebook wirklich anzünden? Oder müssen wir das irgendwie anders machen? Gibt es ein neues Gesetz, was uns helfen kann? All das wollen wir in den folgenden zwei Stunden besprechen. Und zwar einerseits mit den Gästen hier im Studio, die ich euch jetzt mal vorstellen möchte. Hallo, guten Abend. Wir müssen direkt in das Mikrofon, hallo, ha, sehr gut. Das ist Ingo Dachwitz, den ihr gehört habt. Und von Netzpolitik Org, dem Blog. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Hallo. Das letzte Mal zu dir warst du noch Campaignerin. Jetzt bist du Buchautorin, richtig?
Genau.
Aber beide haben sich viel mit dem Thema beschäftigt und werden uns heute sehr genau erklären, was da passiert ist und was das bedeutet. Andererseits wollen wir natürlich auch mit euch reden. Der Hashtag heißt ja Delet-Facebook. Und dann ist ja die Frage, habt ihr jetzt euer Facebook-Account wirklich gelöscht? Oder fragt ihr euch gerade, warum sollte ich das tun? In beiden Fällen könnt ihr gerne anrufen. Unter 0331 70 97 110. Oder direkt vorbeikommen. Wir sind nämlich live aus dem Fritz in der Baumhaus Bar am städtischen Tor. Wenn ihr also noch nichts zu tun habt und denkt, man, so live bei einer Radiosendung dabei sind, mal echt in ein echtes Radiomikrofon sprechen und dann noch was zu Facebook sagen, das geht heute hier im Chaosradio bei Fritz im Blue Moon. So, dann widmen wir uns jetzt mal der Frage, was ist denn eigentlich los? Also wenn man die Nachrichten mitverfolgt hat, ohne sie genau mitzuerfolgen, hat man mitbekommen, ok, Cambridge Analytica, also eine Firma, die vor einem Jahr schon mal in Schlagzeilen war, weil sie angeblich es alleine durch Datenmagie geschafft haben, die war in den USA zu beeinflussen, ist jetzt irgendwie noch mal mehr in Verruf geraten. Und dann hat das irgendwie auch was direkt mit Facebook zu tun. Und zwar so hart, dass Mark Zuckerberg, der Chef von Facebook, ein Interview im Fernsehen gegeben hat, was echt sehr selten ist. Das kann man mitgekriegt haben, wenn man so von außen rausguckt und sich genau verfolgt hat. Was ist denn jetzt passiert? Was ist denn überhaupt das Problem? Es gibt kein Problem? Katascha, was ist das Problem?
Das System ist das Problem, würde ich sagen.
Okay, warte. Lass uns bitte sagen, es ist etwas detaillierter aufdröseln.
Ja, also das Ding, was jetzt quasi passiert ist und durch die Medien gejagt wird, ist eigentlich recht trivial. Das ist eigentlich das, wofür Facebook aus meiner Sicht gebaut wurde. Also Facebook sammelt ja sehr umfassend Daten von uns allen, die wir teilweise freiwillig eingegeben. Teilweise sind es eben Hintergrunddaten, von denen uns gar nicht bewusst ist, dass Facebook sie abgreift. Und eine Sache, die wir ganz bewusst, sage ich mal, bei Facebook offenlegen, sind ja so Sachen wie Likes, wo viele Menschen klicken.
Ich habe das Gefühl, du erklärst jetzt schon auch die Metaebene, also das, was dahinter kommt. Was ist denn eigentlich passiert? Also, weil in den Schlagzeilen war ja nicht Facebook sammelt unsere Daten, sondern der Schlagzeug war ja 50 Millionen?
Genau, diese 50 Millionen geistete immer durch die Medien irgendwie. Cambridge Analytica, diese Wahlbeeinflussungsfirma, Microtargetingfirma, was das ist, können wir dann, wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe, gleich nochmal besprechen, hat eben auf unerlaubtem Wege illegal sozusagen Daten von Facebook bekommen. Und zwar über eine Schnittstelle, die Facebook bis 2015 offen hatte für Programmierer, haben die sozusagen Daten abgegriffen. Und eigentlich sozusagen, das war so der Trick, den die angewendet haben, der auf jeden Fall auch illegal ist, haben die gesagt, haben eine Scheinfirma gehabt quasi, die ein britischer Psychologe, ein Forscher von der Cambridge-Universität gegründet hat. Der hat gesagt, zu Forschungszwecken greife ich hier diese Daten ab, der hat es weitergegeben an diese Firma.
Warte, warte, warte, stopp. Also was ich an der Geschichte schon mal mag, ist, wir machen gerade die ganz einfache Erklärung und da spielt sofort eine Scheinfirma in Großbritannien eine Rolle. Also diese 50 Millionen, also die Daten der 50 Millionen Nutzer sind ja, wie ich hier bin, weggekommen über, also nicht weggekommen, kann man auch gar nicht sagen, sind gesammelt worden über eine App.
Ja, also 270.000 Leute haben gesagt, geil, so eine Psychotest-App, wie sagt mir irgendwie was über meinen Charakter und das ist auch noch für einen guten Zweck eben, für wissenschaftliche Forschung, ja, probiere ich doch mal aus. Und es war lange Zeit so, dass man bei Apps, also wenn man die bei Facebook benutzt hat, sehr weitreichende Zugriffsrechte weitergegeben hat. Das heißt, nicht nur die App durfte auf mein Profil drauf gucken, durfte sehen, wo ich ein Like gesetzt habe, sondern auch die, also ich habe damit quasi auch die Daten meiner Freunde weitergegeben, ohne dass es mir unter Umständen bewusst war. Und so kommt diese hohe Zahl von 50 Millionen zu Stande. Das waren quasi die Freunde von Nutzern und die Nutzer selbst dieser App.
Und das geht jetzt aber nicht mehr, ne? Ich bin nämlich bei einer App an und die Daten meiner Freunde sind dann auch gleich mit drin. Das hat zumindest gesagt worden.
Das haben die dicht gemacht, eigentlich diese Schiffstelle.
So, und diese App ist also von einem Typen programmiert, der heißt Krogan oder sowas?
Genau, Alexander Krogan.
Alexander Krogan, genau.
Und also der war, das hör ich jetzt gerade erst, der war als Assistenzprofessor in Cambridge beschäftigt und hat da schon lange geforscht zu diesem Thema, wie kann man eigentlich mit Like-Daten oder Facebook-Daten psychologische Profile erstellen, Psychographie nennen die das, also die Vermessung der Psyche quasi, und daraus dann eben Verhalten, Vorhersagen und auf dieser Grundlage dann beeinflussen. Da hat er geforscht und der ist irgendwie mit dieser dubiosen Firma Cambridge Analytica in Kontakt gekommen. Und auf dem Wege hat er dann diese App entwickelt und in den App Store gestellt, hat gesagt, hier für wissenschaftliche Zwecke nehmt teil an dieser Studie. Ich sag euch sozusagen, was eure Persönlichkeit ist hier oder welches euer Secret Animal ist oder was auch immer der da gesagt hat.
Das muss man an der Punkt auch sagen. Also diese ganzen Apps, die es gibt, also welcher Harry Potter Schal bist du? Was ist dein Krafttier? Das sind alles diese Apps, die im Prinzip genau darüber funktionieren. Sie geben dir einen Zugriff an Facebook oder sie nehmen einen Zugriff an Facebook und können auch genau dasselbe machen. Oder?
Genau, das ist das Prinzip der Inter, beziehungsweise offensichtlich ist es so gewesen, dass das nicht nur freiwillige Nutzerinnen und Nutzer waren, die diese App genutzt haben, sondern die haben offensichtlich auch noch über diese Plattform Amazon Mechanical Turk, wo man eben so Mikroarbeiten vergeben kann für so ein paar Dollar, Leute dafür angeheuert, dass sie das machen. Also so digitale Billiglöhner, Clickworker quasi, die sollen eben auch dafür bezahlt worden sein, diese App mitzumachen.
Die haben quasi also ihre Freunde ohne unerst gewollt.
Also dieses Mechanical Turk, das ist ja so für so arbeiten. Ich habe hier ein unleserliches PDF, kannst du mir das abschreiben. Und dann haben die also gesagt, du kriegst Geld, wenn du an diesem Test teilnimmst.
Genau.
Dann haben die aber natürlich mit ihrem Profil gemacht und dann auch noch ihre Freunde quasi mitverkauft.
Das war die Voraussetzung dafür, dass sie das mit ihrem Profil machen und über diesen Umweg sozusagen, ich glaube insgesamt kursiert die Zahl 800.000 Dollar, sollen eben von Cambridge Analytica insgesamt geflossen sein an diese Scheinfirma von dem Kogan und dann weitergezahlt an die Mechanical Turks.
Und jetzt kommen wir tatsächlich zum ersten Mal zum Punkt, was Katascha gerade meinte. Das ist ja das, was Facebook macht. Also dieses, man apps und dann kann man damit daten. Und der illegale Teil der Verstoß gegen die Geschäftsbedingungen war ja dieser Weiterverkauf nur.
Genau, also es gibt beides sozusagen, ist ein Thema, das System dahinter. Aber da hat Facebook sich dann ja auch immer darauf rausgeredet, nein, wir sind aufs Glatteis geführt worden und wir sind hier die, wir sind die Betrogenen, wir sind die Opfer. Das konnten wir ja nicht wissen, dass der so unverantwortlich mit den Daten abgibt, die er umgeht, die er hier abbreitet.
Weil man sagen muss, dass das ja absoluter Quatsch ist, wenn man sich mal die Faktenlage anguckt. Ja, also Facebook wurde schon von Jahren vom Datenschutzaktivisten Max Schrems darauf hingewiesen, dass es nicht nur moralisch, sondern auch rechtlich durchaus ein Problem gibt bei dieser Weitergabe von Daten von Freunden an Apps. Und Facebook hat da auch ganz offiziell bekanntgegeben, sie sehen darin kein Problem. Und es ist später auch bekannt geworden, dass Facebook durchaus wusste, dass es diesen Datendeal gab zwischen Cambridge Analytica und eben dieser App. Sie haben daraufhin Cambridge Analytica angemahnt, na na, löscht mal die Daten, bitte. Ja, aber wer löscht denn bitte schon seine Geschäftsgrundlage aufgrund einer Bitte? Und das ist dann natürlich nicht passiert. Und man hat sich bei Facebook offensichtlich ganz bewusst dafür entschieden, die Nutzer nicht zu informieren.
Wenn ihr euch gerade fragt, warum ist da um Gottes Willen eine Sirene im Fritz-Studio, ist es deswegen, weil wir heute live sein. Und aus dem Vorland Fritz, ihr könnt gerne noch selber vorbeikommen und statt Sirenengeräusche ins Mikrofon sprechen. Falkensteinstraße 47, die Adresse ist am schlesischen Tor. Oder ruft an 0331 70 97 110. So, um das noch mal ganz klar auseinanderzuhalten. Also das eine Ding ist, diese App sammelt Daten und die meiner Freunde. Das ist aber das, was Facebook zumindest in der Zeitung noch gemacht hat. Und das andere ist, diese gesammelten Daten sind dann weiterverkauft worden. Oder sagen, zwischen den Firmen hin und her geschachert. Und da hat Facebook gesagt, naja, da können wir nichts dafür verstoßen. Und da gab es dann aber wiederum Menschen, die Facebook von innen so ein bisschen kennen, die gesagt haben, naja, das weite man schon aussehen, das, was du gerade erzählt hast.
Genau. Also es gab immer wieder Insider, die jetzt an die Presse gegangen sind und gesagt haben, naja, uns war schon klar, dass es quasi einen Schwarzmarkt für Daten gibt, die über diese Apps abgegriffen werden. Weil da liegt natürlich auch ein finanzielles Interesse darin, solche Daten zu bekommen und für kommerzielle Zwecke auszuwerten.
Und Facebook sozusagen hatte selber die Motivation, die hatten damals noch die Idee, dass es denn ein Teil deren Geschäftsmodell sein könnte, dass sie sozusagen über das, was die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer in den Apps, so in Appkäufe ausgeben an Geld, dafür haben die 30 Prozent genommen damals. Deshalb hatten die sozusagen eine Motivation, die App-Programmierer einfach mal machen zu lassen quasi.
Ach so, also Facebook hat gesagt, ja, wir machen das mit den Daten, also Gedanken machen wir uns ja nicht. Sondern ihr könnt erst mal so, wir wollen mal gucken, wie viel da rauszieht oder wie.
Also das ist jedenfalls meine Theorie oder meine Lesart davon. Das war sozusagen so ein bisschen der Deal, die Entwickler, die da Dritt-Apps geben oder Dritt-Apps bei Facebook am Start hatten, die mussten 30 Prozent für jeden In-App-Kauf abdrücken, quasi an Facebook. Darüber wollte Facebook sich auch mal teilfinanzieren. Und im Gegenzug sozusagen dafür, dass die dann 30 Prozent abdrücken, hat Facebook gesagt, wir gucken da halt einfach nicht so genau hin.
Okay, da muss man aber auch wieder sagen, also das sagt dann aber in dem Fall nur, das erklärt, warum es diese Art des Datenabflusses gibt, aber hier sind nicht User um Geld gekommen und Userinnen sozusagen. Genau, diese App war sogar hart. Also wir wollen uns sozusagen im weiteren Verlauf der Sendung schon vor allen Dingen damit beschäftigen, was denn mit diesen ganzen Daten passiert. Wir müssen aber jetzt am Anfang, glaube ich, wenigstens wenn wir also gerade komplett über das Problem reden, nochmal über diese Cambridge Analytica Firma reden. Also was ist denn das, was die mit den Daten gemacht haben oder vorgeben, damit gemacht zu haben? Das scheint ja auch sozusagen, da scheint ja auch so viel Magie dahinter zu sein. Es ging ja um die Wahlen in den USA. Mittlerweile wird auch sozusagen auch spekuliert, haben die auch beim Brexit in Großbritannien mitgemacht. Also weiß man da irgendwas genau, was sie da gemacht haben?
Also man nennt das, was sie da mitgemacht haben, Microtargeting quasi, also das, was in der digitalen Werbung eigentlich an der Tagesordnung ist, nämlich eben Botschaften so zu schneiden auf kleinere Zielgruppen, dass sie möglichst eine Wirkung erzielen, die man möchte. Und das haben sie eben auf der Grundlage der Daten, auf der psychologischen Profile, die sie hatten, über die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer gemacht. Also als Beispiel, wenn jemand irgendwie anfällig für Verschwörungstheorien ist, neurotisch, weiß man, was für eine politische Botschaft, wie man den politisch ansprechen muss, als Trump-Kampagne beispielsweise.
Also ich muss an der Stelle ganz genau bleiben, das ist die Idee, die die da haben. Also die Idee ist sozusagen, die können aus den Daten rauslesen, der Richter, der ist total neurotisch. Wenn wir denen jetzt irgendwie die richtige Werbung einspielen, dann wählt er den Trump.
Ja, also es ist tatsächlich wissenschaftlich fundiert, was sich jetzt so ein bisschen wie Magie anhört. Und zwar ist es so, dass wenn man unseren Charakter oder unsere Schwachstellen kennt, dann weiß man schon ganz genau, was uns anspricht. Also um es mal ganz vereinfacht zu sagen. Also wenn man jetzt beispielsweise sagt, der Richter, der ist so ein bisschen neurotisch, dann fragt man sich ja, okay, wie haben wir das rausgefunden? Keiner hat Zeit, alle Postings von dem Richter zu lesen. Um herauszufinden, ist der jetzt wirklich neurotisch. Sondern man guckt sich beispielsweise die Likes an. Und das kann man automatisiert auswerten. Und da gibt es eben vergleichende Studien von Leuten, die eben so einen Psychotest gemacht haben beispielsweise, wo man abgleichen kann, Leute, die neurotisch sind, die liken im Durchschnitt folgende Seiten oder haben folgendes Muster an Likes. Und dann kann man schon abgleichen und sagen, naja, der ist mit so und so viel Wahrscheinlichkeit zu so und so viel Prozent neurotisch. Und das macht ihn laut wissenschaftlichen Studien besonders empfänglich für folgende Botschaften.
Aber das, also okay, also man kann also an dem Ding ablesen, wie der Charakter eines Menschen ist. An dieser Stelle einen herzlichen Gruß an die Rosa Rabattmarken. Eine obskure Band, die, glaube ich, zwei Fans hat. Einer davon bin ich. Mitleidsleid für meinen Bruder. Und andererseits, also man glaubt dazu wissen, oder man weiß sozusagen, man kann den Charakter einschätzen. Aber dieses, man weiß dann, auf was der anspricht. Gibt es einen Beweis dafür, dass man mit Facebook-Werbung tatsächlich Verhalten ändert oder generell Online-Werbung?
Ja, also es gab eine Studie, die hat sich mal angeguckt, wie funktioniert das eigentlich mit personalisierter Werbung. Und die haben bei einer sehr, sehr großen Zahl von Nutzern in Großbritannien und USA haben Werbung ausgespielt und haben sich nur einen einzigen Like genommen, der laut Vermutung sagen soll, ob jemand eher introvertiert oder extrovertiert ist. Das war in dem Fall beispielsweise so ein Like, mag Partys, ist in Gruppen, die irgendwas mit Partys zu tun haben. Und die introvertierten Leute hatten interessanterweise angeblich eine Vorliebe für Computer. Und dann haben sie eben in Schritt zwei zwei unterschiedliche Anzeigen gemacht und geguckt, naja, die psychologisch angepasste Anzeige, wird die mehr geklickt als die andere und zu wie viel Verkaufsabschlüssen in diesem Fall bei einem Beauty-Produkt hat das denn geführt? Also um es mal plakativ zu machen, auf der einen Anzeige war dann so ein, also es richtete sich an Frauen, war dann so ein Mädchen, das eher so schüchtern aussah vom Spiegel und dann war irgendwas über Schönheit drunter geschrieben und auf dem anderen Bild war dann so ein wild tanzenes Mädchen auf der Mitte von der Tanzfläche. Und dann war auch irgendwas über kaufen sie Beauty-Produkte geschrieben. Und allein anhand eines Likes konnten die eben feststellen, dass bis zu 50 Prozent mehr Kaufabschlüsse getätigt wurden. Das heißt, man kann damit schon die Wirksamkeit von Anzeigen immens steigern.
Jetzt würde ich also trotzdem sagen wir mal zumindest hoffen, dass der Verkauf eines ein paar Euro Beauty-Produkts etwas anderes ist als eine Wahlentscheidung.
Wobei ich noch sagen würde, dass Werbung für Dinge, die ich kaufen kann, für mich eher leichter erkennbar sind als Werbung. Bei vielen Menschen ist es so, dass wenn etwas in meinem Newsfeed vorbei läuft und es ist politisch, meine erste Assoziation ja nicht ist, okay, das ist bezahlte Werbung und manche gucken da eben nicht so genau hin. Es gab eine Studie beispielsweise von Jugendlichen in Großbritannien, die gezeigt hat, dass über die Hälfte der Nutzer nicht mal gecheckt hat, dass die ersten Anzeigen bei Google bezahlte Werbeanzeigen sind, obwohl Fett daneben Anzeige steht. Von daher würde ich sogar die These aufstellen, dass es bei politischer Werbung noch effektiver ist als bei kommerzieller.
Das ist natürlich eine sehr spannende Frage, wie das wirkt. Es gibt nicht besonders viele Studien dazu.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen irritiert, weil ich im Rahmen dieser ganzen Skalpern, Skalpern, Social Boards und Fake News und so, das ist ja im letzten Jahr ganz viel diskutiert worden. Ich habe mehrere Interviews gehabt mit Wissenschaftlern, die in dem Bereich arbeiten und die waren alle so, ah, also wir glauben da nicht so richtig dran, dass man, dass man damit wirklich hart Meinung beeinflussen kann, sondern das ist eher so sehr viel heiße Luft. Und höre ich dich jetzt anders? Glaubst du, dass sie das nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen wollen oder?
Ja, also ich denke, also um jetzt mal noch mal klar zu sagen, ich glaube nicht, dass man mit so einer Werbeanzeige die Meinung von jemanden um 180 Grad drehen kann. Aber wenn man sich mal knappe Wahlergebnisse anschaut, wo nur ein paar tausend Leute vielleicht in dem Bundesstaat oder in einem Bundesland darüber entscheiden, wer die Mehrheit bekommt, dann kann dieses kleine Prozent bei Unentschlossenen schon dazu führen, dass das Gewicht in die eine oder andere Richtung verschoben wird. Und wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie viel Milliarden Euro, ich glaube, das waren mehr als 500, nee 200 Milliarden Euro oder so mittlerweile für Online-Werbung rausgeballert werden, dann wäre es ja naiv anzunehmen, die Leute würden das machen, wenn es keinen Effekt hat.
Man kann es ja mal an konkreten Beispielen aus der Trump-Kampagne festmachen. Also wir müssen uns vor Augen halten, die US-Wahl ist super knapp ausgegangen. In etwa sind so am Ende 70.000 Stimmen gewesen, verteilt über drei Bundesstaaten, die dann die Entscheidung gegeben haben. Und also ein gutes Beispiel finde ich eben, dass bekannt ist, dass die Trump-Kampagne für den Haustür-Wahlkampf mit sozusagen unterschiedlichen Gesprächsleitfäden an die Leute rangegangen sind. Die hatten 32 unterschiedliche Gesprächsleitfäden, die dann eben ein bisschen darauf abgestimmt sind, okay, wie groß ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Person für uns wählt, mit welchen Themen kann ich da besser punkten gehen? Ist das jemand, bei dem ich mit Waffenthemen besser vorankomme oder mit Einwanderung?
Da muss ich dir jetzt betätigen, Frage stellen, Haustür-Wahlkampf ist jetzt nicht Facebook.
Nee, genau, aber das ist ja das, was mit den Facebook-Daten dann passiert ist. Die können ja nicht nur auf Facebook eingesetzt werden. Wenn du erst mal diese Profile hast von 50 Millionen Leuten und die sozusagen psychografische Profile angelicht hast, dann kannst du die ja überall verwenden.
Ja, also das muss man eben auch immer als, sag ich mal, Gesamtpaket sehen. Es hat nicht nur Trump gemacht, es hat genauso Hillary Clinton gemacht und Obama hat das ja, sag ich mal, erstmals in großem Stil im Wahlkampf eingesetzt. Und da war es so, dass eben einerseits Daten gekauft wurden, beispielsweise von Paypal oder anderen großen Unternehmen. Und die wurden wiederum angereichert mit dem, was die Leute auch als Feedback gegeben haben von Haustür-Wahlkämpfen. Das heißt, da sind analoge und digitale Datensammlungen dann zusammengeflossen. Und ja, man wusste dann genau, wer ist auf der Kippe, bei wem es lohnt, sich anzuklopfen, weil den können wir vielleicht noch überzeugen, der ist wirklich unentflossen.
Also ich will den Punkt einmal versuchen zusammenzufassen. Also die Gefahr, die man da sieht, ist nicht, durch Facebook-Datenmagie kann ich ein ganzes Land davon überzeugen, die Marcus Richter-Partei zu wählen, sondern es ist eher so, ich kann durch sehr genaue Datenanalyse vielleicht den 0, 5%-Anteil der Menschheit finden, die sich noch umstimmen lassen und muss dann hoffen, dass die Wahl halt so knapp ist, dass das einen Unterschied macht.
Und es gibt noch einen zweiten Anwendungsfall. Die Trump-Kampagne hat bewusst auf Negative-Campagning gesetzt. Das gibt es ja in den USA sowieso, eine viel stärkere Tradition für. Aber die haben sozusagen strategische Demobilisierung versucht. So nennt man es eben. Also die haben gezielt versucht, nicht mehr Leute, auch nicht nur Leute von Trump, davon zu überzeugen, Trump zu wählen, sondern eben Hillary-Wähler, potenzielle Hillary-Wähler, die auf der Kippe stehen, davon abzuhalten, zur Wahl zu gehen. Also es ist zum Beispiel inzwischen ganz gut dokumentiert, dass beispielsweise sozusagen People of Color in den USA von der Trump-Kampagne Anzeigen bekommen haben, in denen ein alter Video-Ausschnitt von Hillary Clinton aus den 90ern gezeigt wurde, in denen sie sozusagen den Begriff Superpredators für so kriminelle afroamerikanische Jugendbanden benutzt hat. Also sozusagen haben gezielt da die Impulse gesetzt, dann bei denen eine Vorstellung von einer rassistischen Einstellung bei Hillary zu erzeugen, um die sozusagen zu demotivieren, hinzugehen. Das gleiche ist mit Frauen, die sich für Feminismus interessieren. Da gab es dann Anzeigen, die irgendwie das Fremdgehen von Bill Clinton thematisiert haben beispielsweise, um die davon abzuhalten zur Wahl zu gehen.
Das neue, was wir eben auch bei Online-Wahlkämpfen mit Mikro-Targeting haben, ist, dass bei einem normalen Wahlkampf kommt ein Wahlwerbespot im Fernsehen und dann reden da auch alle drüber. Also was werden da für Argumente verwendet und so weiter und so fort. Bei Mikro-Targeting und bei Facebook kann man auch sogenannte Dark Posts ausspielen. Das heißt, wirklich nur diese Zielgruppe bekommt, die zu sehen. Das heißt, es ist auch für Medienberichterstattung oder eben auch den politischen Wettbewerber schwierig zu sehen, was macht eigentlich der Gegenspieler so ein bisschen. Oder mit was wird mir eigentlich vorgeworfen, weil ich es überhaupt nicht mitbekomme unter Umständen. Und damit haben wir so eine fragmentierte Öffentlichkeit, die ja auch das Zusammenspiel von Wahlkämpfen vollkommen ändert.
So, dann haben wir jetzt in der ersten halben Stunde geklärt, was das grundlegende Problem im Ergebnis dieses aktuellen Cambridge Analytica Facebook-Skandals ist. Jetzt ist aber, dass die Diskussion darüber so weit fortkommt, dass man sagen kann, na ja, das Ganze ist ja so ein bisschen größer, weil wir haben das ganze Problem überhaupt sowieso nur, weil es diese Mengen von Daten gibt. Was da genau drin steht und wie man das machen kann, das reden wir im weiteren Vortrag der Sendung noch. Jetzt eine kurze erste Pause, wo es erst mal die Nerd-News gibt, dann eine kleine Musik und dann die Nachrichten. Und dann geht es hier weiter im Chaosradio im Blue Moon.
Die Transportverschlüsselung TLS 1.3, die Datenpakete im Internet verschlüsselt, ist als Standard der Internet Engineering Task Force IETF verabschiedet worden. Sie bringt modernere Verschlüsselungen. Außerdem wird schon der Verbindungsaufbau kryptographisch gesichert. Behörden, Banken und Betreiber von Rechenzentren forderten bis zuletzt Nachschlüssel, konnten sich aber nicht durchsetzen. Daher kündigten sie an, sich beim European Telecom Standards Institute für einen Gegenstandard einzusetzen, der ihren Wünschen entspricht. Nach dem tödlichen Unfall mit einem autonom fahrenden Auto wurden den Betreibern des Fahrzeugs alle weiteren Testfahrten in Arizona untersagt. Der Gouverneur des US-Bundesstaates teilte mit, dass Uber bei seinen Tests nicht wie erwartet die Sicherheit oben angestellt habe. In Zeitungsberichten wurden interne Uber-Dokumente zitiert, nach denen die selbstfahrenden Fahrzeuge Schwierigkeiten an Baustellen und neben Sattelschleppern gehabt haben sollen. Außerdem hätten menschliche Sicherheitsfahrer häufig eingreifen müssen. Alle 12 von der israelischen Sicherheitsfirma CTS Labs gefundenen Sicherheitslücken in AMD-Chip-Sätzen und Prozessoren wurden vom Hersteller offiziell bestätigt. Um die Lücken, die als AMD-Flaws bezeichnet werden, zu schließen, sind laut AMD Firmware-Updates notwendig. Die Patches für Risenfall, Masterkey und Fallout werden in den nächsten Wochen per BIOS-Update von den Hardware-Herstellern zur Verfügung gestellt. Bei der Sicherheitslücke Chimera gibt es noch keinen Zeitplan. Im Unterschied zu den Patches für die im Januar veröffentlichten Prozessorlücken Spectre und Meltdown soll es bei denen für AMD-Flaws keine Performance-Einbußen geben.
Die Night News vom Chaos Computer Club, geschrieben von Moe, vorgetragen von Helena. Sie kommt von King Ski vom Album Red und heißt Walk. Danach gibt es hier die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Und Fritz präsentiert Justin Timberlake.
Es ist 22.32 Uhr.
Mit Benedikt Wenck.
Wegen des religiösen Mobbings an manchen Schulen fordern einige Zuwandererverbände einen Neuanfang in der Islampolitik. Der Präsident der Bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft der Immigrantenverbände in Deutschland fordert, dass etwa Parteien, Kirchen und Stiftungen die Zusammenarbeit mit Vertretern des politischen Islams einstellen. Außerdem hat der Vorsitzende davor gewarnt, dass es immer mehr Kinder aus muslimischen Elternhäusern gäbe, die andere Schüler angriffen und beschimpften, weil diese nicht an Allah glaubten.
Bundesfamilienministerin Giffey will sich für eine bessere Bezahlung von Kita-
Erzieherinnen und Erziehern einsetzen. Sie besuchte heute zusammen mit Berlins Bildungssenatorin Scheres eine Kita in Berlin-Marzahn. Dort sagte sie, dass sie sich eine ähnlich hohe Bezahlung wie für Grundschullehrerinnen vorstellen kann. Der genaue Lohn sei aber noch Verhandlungssache. Giffey will außerdem den Pflegeberuf aufwerten. Die Oscar-Akademie ruft Nachwuchsregisseure in aller Welt auf, sich mit ihren Filmen für den sogenannten Studenten-Oscar zu bewerben. Studenten können ihre Werke bis zum 1. Juni einreichen. Die Preise werden im Oktober in Hollywood vergeben. 2017 haben neben US-Bewerbern auch zwei Deutsche gewonnen.
Johannes Preuß von der Filmakademie Baden-Württemberg mit einer Reportage und Katja Behnrath von der Hamburg Media School mit einem Kurzfilm.
Mit einem Gegentreffer. In letzter Sekunde haben die Füchse Berlin heute einen Sieg verpasst. Am Ende mussten sie sich den Handballen in Stuttgart mit einem 24 zu 24 zufriedengeben. Die Eisbären Berlin konnten sich im DEL Playoff-Halbfinale dafür gegen die Nürnberg Eiszeigers durchsetzen. Da hieß es am Ende 5 zu 1. Und in der Basketball-Bundesliga, da hat sich Alba Berlin gegen die Rockets Erfurt mit 98 zu 68 durchgesetzt. In Berlin waren sie 4 und Atlashof 6 Grad, Rheinsberg 3, Eberswalde und Wiesenburg 4 und Frankfurt oder 5 Grad. Nachts bleibt es erstmal überwiegend trocken mit lockeren Wolken, bis am Morgen dann stellenweise Nebel aufkommt.
Die Temperaturen sinken auf minus 3 bis 0 Grad.
Am Karfreitag dann generell eher schön.
Die Sonne scheint auch bei länger, dazu milde Temperaturen von 8 bis 13 Grad.
Der Rest der Feiertage eher wechselhaft und kühler.
Erst am Ostermontag wird es dann wieder freundlicher.
Auf der B96 heuer's Wärter baut es zwischen Schwarzkolm, Altstadt und Nahrt nach einem Unfall Vollsperrungen in beiden Richtungen. Wenn möglich das Gebiet weiträumig umfahren.
Und noch ein genereller Hinweis, in Berlin und Brandenburg muss in den Nachtstunden bis Karfreitagmorgen mit Glätte auf Straßen und Wegen gerechnet werden.
Wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal fritz.de slash Tipps.
Zurück im Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Fritz, heute live aus dem Fräulein Fritz in der Fallensteinstraße 47. Ihr könnt gerne vorbeikommen und erklären, warum ihr euren Facebook-Account gelöscht habt oder anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Denn das ist das Thema heute hier im Chaosradio im Blue Moon mit Katascha und Ingo. Willkommen zurück. Ihr müsst schon in die Mikrofonische reden, sonst klappt das heute nicht mit dem Radio. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde erklärt, was hinter dem Cambridge Analytica-Skandal steckt. Also versucht, nochmal genau zu zeigen, worüber wird sich denn eigentlich aufgeregt und erfahren, dass es im Grunde genommen so ein ganzes Microtargeting geht. Also herauszufinden, wem muss ich was ganz genau sagen, damit sich dann unter Umständen seine politische Meinung so ändert, dass er ein Wahlergebnis produziert, das mir genügsam ist, indem er entweder meinen Kandidaten wählt oder nicht wählen geht, weil er möglicherweise einen anderen Kandidaten oder Kandidatin gewählt hätte. Und die Stelle sozusagen, wo es interessant war, dass man gesagt hat, das macht man, indem man ganz viele Daten von Facebook verarbeitet und wie es dazu gekommen ist, das haben wir alles geklärt. Jetzt wollen wir genau darüber nochmal sprechen, über diese Daten. Und das Spannende ist, dass Katarscha, die heute hier ist, mal versucht hat, herauszufinden, was Facebook alles so über sie weiß. Warum, wieso und was stand dann drin?
Ja, also die Geschichte hat damit angefangen, dass ich für mein Buch die Daten, die ich rief, recherchiert habe, was für einen Datenschatten ich persönlich hinterlassen habe, bei Unternehmen und auch anderswo. Und da liegt es natürlich nahe bei Facebook mal anzufragen. Und das Problem bei Facebook ist, dass man nur ein Teil seines Datenpakets bekommt. Man kann aber ein Teil seines Datenpakets anfordern. In den Einstellungen gibt es da so einen Menüpunkt. Und da kann man eben sagen, ich möchte eine Kopie meiner Daten haben. Und das dauert dann meistens so ein paar Tage. Und dann kriegt man einen Download Link. Und wenn man da draufklickt, kriegt man dann so ein ganzes Datenpaket, wo dann so ein Bruchteil der Daten, die Facebook über einen gespeichert hat, drin sind. Ja, und das hab ich mal für mich gemacht vor einigen Monaten. Und fand das doch schon recht interessant, was aus dem kleinen Teil der Daten allein schon rauszulesen war. Also zum einen war es so, dass, oder ist es so, dass Facebook natürlich die IP-Adressen speichert, mit denen ich mich einwähle. Ja, da kann man unterschiedliche Meinungen zu haben, dass es vielleicht für die letzten Besuche sinnvoll ist, zu gucken, damit ich selber auch sehen kann, wer ist eigentlich eingeloggt, von wo. Naja, aber ob man das jetzt für ein halbes Jahr rückwirkend unbedingt machen muss oder auch länger, ich weiß ja nicht, ob Facebook mir alles rausgerückt hat, darüber streiten sich die Geister. Ja, und dann hab ich mir mal angeguckt, was für IPs bei mir so drin sind, und zack, mein kompletter Urlaub konnte darüber nachvollzogen werden. Also ich bin mit dem Auto von Berlin ins Ruhrgebiet und dann in die Schweiz, nach Zermatt, und dann nach Barcelona zum Festival gefahren und dann wieder zurück. Und das konnte man alles nachvollziehen anhand der IP-Adressen, mit denen ich mich da eingewählt hab. So, und als nächstes habe ich mir dann noch so andere Daten angeguckt. Da war beispielsweise mein Fotoordner, der in meinem Fall nicht besonders prall ist, weil ich Facebook privat nicht nutze. Und bei den Fotos war es so, dass bei einigen Fotodateien sogenannte Exif-Daten dabei waren. Das sind so, sag ich mal, Zusatzinformationen, die automatisch vom Fotogerät, also entweder dem Smartphone oder der Kamera mit in eine Fotodatei eingelegt werden, abgelegt werden, wenn ich das entsprechend eingestellt hab. Und beim Smartphone kann das eben auch der Standort sein, also sag ich mal die GPS-Daten. Und ja, das war halt auch mit dabei bei einigen Fotos.
Ich will mal kurz noch mit dem Exif so ein bisschen genauer erklären. Also das ist, das sind also sogenannte Metadaten für Bilder. Und die sind, die meisten Smartphones sind auch so eingestellt, dass sie das automatisch mit abspeichern, mit Bild. Und wenn ihr euch das selber mal angucken wollt, kann man googeln, das heißt dann Exif Viewer. Also das ist auch kein Hexenwerk, man sieht das als normaler Mensch nicht, weil diese Bilder, man sieht halt immer nur die Bilder. Aber es gibt sozusagen einfache Programme, wo man sich das anzeigen lassen kann. Oder falls man irgendwo ein Bildbearbeitungsprogramm rumliegen hat, dann können die das meistens auch an irgendeiner Stelle. Das ist also nichts, was besonders versteckt ist, aber es weiß halt kaum einer. Und diese Daten sozusagen standen dann in deinen Daten auch drin. Also quasi auch als Text schon rausgezogen, dass man da sehen konnte, wo hast du immer schön fotografiert oder wie?
Ja, also zu den einzelnen Bilddateien war dann eben noch eine Angabe. Da hat man dann beispielsweise gesehen, ich hab mit einer Nikon-Kamera das eine Bild gemacht und das andere eben mit einem Smartphone. Und bei den Smartphone-Bildern dort, wo ich auch, muss ich sagen, absichtlich zu Testzwecken die Standortdaten dann mit abgespeichert hab, da war es dann auch sichtbar. Wobei man sagen muss, dass Facebook diese Daten, soweit man das nicht freigegeben hat, also die Standortdaten auch rausfiltert. Aber trotzdem finde ich es natürlich problematisch. Wie rausfiltert?
Die werden dann nicht angezeigt im sozialen Netzwerk, aber Facebook weiß sie trotzdem.
Ja klar, also Facebook speichert das dann bis auf alle Ewigkeit wahrscheinlich. Ja und noch ein anderer Punkt, den ich sehr spannend finde und wo ich jedem nur raten kann, sich mal so ein bisschen mit seinem Datenprofil zu befassen und sich so eine Kopie der Daten auch auszuziehen, war der Punkt der sogenannten Custom Audiences oder auch Werbeanzeigen. Also ich konnte in meinem, ja in diesem Datensatz auch sehen, auf welche Werbung ich geklickt hatte. Das war genau eine. Was aber viel interessanter war, ich konnte sehen, welche Unternehmen meine E-Mail-Adresse mit Facebook abgeglichen haben. Und wie funktioniert das? Das funktioniert so, wenn ich als Unternehmen ja targeted advertisement, also so Mikro-Targeting beispielsweise machen will bei Facebook, kann ich eben auch sagen, ich gleiche einfach meine komplette Kunden-Datenbank, die E-Mail-Adressen oder Telefonnummern gleiche ich eben mit Facebook ab. Und Facebook spuckt mir dann raus, wo ein Treffer ist, also was das zugehörige Facebook-Profil zum entsprechenden Kunden ist. Und jetzt ist es so, dass einige Unternehmen wie beispielsweise Pizza.de in ihren AGB auch drinstehen haben, wir machen das. In meiner Liste war allerdings dann auch so ein größerer IT-Hardware-Händler, der hatte das nicht drinstehen, der hatte stattdessen drinstehen, wir werden deine Daten niemals an Dritte weitergeben. Das war dann ein bisschen ernüchternd. Da hab ich mich natürlich beschwert. Was haben Sie dann gesagt? Erstmal hat sich der Datenschutzbeauftragte sehr lange nicht gemeldet. Komisch. Dann hab ich mich längere Zeit doch sehr penetrant gemeldet. Dann bekam ich irgendwann auch einen Brief, dass man mit der Marketing-Abteilung gesprochen hätte. Die Marketing-Abteilung hätte das gemacht, man hätte das nicht machen dürfen und wird das in Zukunft nicht machen. Aber was mir dann im Endeffekt auch nicht mehr hilft, da ist das Kind in den Brunnen gefallen, die Informationen, die ich bei diesem Händler eingekauft hab, die ich unter Umständen Facebook überhaupt nicht geben will, die wurde dann mit meinem Profil verknüpft. Weil wenn ich da nicht eingekauft hätte, warum sollte ich in der Datenbank sein? Ja. In so einem Facebook-Profil, was man sich dann runterladen kann, sind auch noch andere Sachen, beispielsweise alle Freundschaften. Da sieht man auch, wer den ersten Schritt gemacht hat. Das heißt, wer hat eine Freundschaftsanfrage gestellt. Das heißt, Facebook hat nicht nur, nach außen sieht man ja nur, wer ist mit wem befreundet. Im Hintergrund ist es aber so, dass Facebook natürlich viel umfassendere Daten hat und weiß, wer hat den ersten Schritt bei wem getan. Und wer hat vielleicht auch den ersten Schritt getan, um eine Freundschaft zu beenden. Was ich dann doch schon sehr erschreckend fand, obwohl ich persönlich Facebook privat nicht nutze, sondern nur für Öffentlichkeitskram war dann einfach alle Nachrichten und alle Direktnachrichten, die man jemals geschrieben hat, da noch mal zu sehen. Ich glaube, das ist einem theoretisch natürlich klar. Das Internet vergisst nicht und Facebook ganz besonders nicht, weil da ein kommerzielles Interesse hinter steht. Aber das noch einmal vor Augen zu haben, ist dann noch mal etwas ganz anderes. Ich nutze Facebook noch nicht so lange. Aus beruflichen Gründen musste ich mir einen Account anlegen, weil ich sonst eine Seite nicht hätte managen können. Ich will mir erst gar nicht vorstellen, was man da alles rausbekommt, wenn man das seit seiner Schulzeit, seit seiner Studienzeit genutzt hat. Dann sind natürlich auch alle Veranstaltungen, die ich jemals besucht habe, da vermerkt. Alle Veranstaltungen, zu denen ich eingeladen wurde. Bei mir war dann sozusagen auch so Sachen drin, wie Katharina Nocun interessiert sich für das Ende der Monogamie. Das war eine Lesung. Tatsächlich interessiere mich mich, ich halte das Ende der Monogamie noch nicht für gekommen. Jedenfalls nicht für mich. Aber da macht man sich in dem Moment natürlich Gedanken. Ich hab da irgendwie so leichtfertig geklickt, vielleicht auch aus Höflichkeit, weil ich den Autor kenne. Und auch schätze. Aber was für ein Bild generiert das eigentlich von?
Also wollte ich gerade fragen, hast du das mal entweder selber gemacht oder möglicherweise diese Daten sogar weitergegeben, um mal zu gucken, was kann man denn über dich lernen nur aus diesem Datensatz?
Ja, also aus diesem Datensatz kann man aus mir schon einiges lernen, aber ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es bei Facebook-Intensivnutzer noch viel spannender ist. Also Leute, die tatsächlich auf Sachen, die sie mögen, bei ein Like setzen. Das mach ich nicht wirklich. Und bei mir ist es auch so, ich habe explizit natürlich nicht meine Adressbücher mit Facebook abgeglichen. Von daher ist dieser Bereich da leer. Aber trotz allem, ja, also natürlich wäre es interessanter, jemanden mal draufgucken zu lassen, vor allem wenn man das ganze Profil hätte. Also es gab mal den Fall, dass der Datenschutzaktivist Max Schrems seine Daten auch wirklich, also drauf bestanden hat, gerichtlich auch, dass er diese Daten vollständig bekommt. Und der hat dann 1222 PDF-Seiten, glaube ich, bekommen. Und da waren dann auch noch Nachrichten drin, die er nie abgeschickt hat, die er gelöscht hat. Und das eigentlich Spannende bei Facebook sind ja nur teilweise die öffentlichen Sachen oder die Sachen, die ich bewusst mache. Viel interessanter ist es ja, was für Daten werden im Hintergrund beispielsweise durch den Like-Button auf externen Seiten gesammelt, auch wenn ich nicht draufklicke.
Das funktioniert so.
Das musst du gerade sagen. Moment. Das ist also noch ein weiteres Problem oder eine weitere Sache. Die eine Sache ist, Facebook sammelt also Daten, wenn man auf Facebook ist.
Ja, also beispielsweise, welchen Profil habe ich nach einer Party mir ein paar Mal angeguckt, weil ich vielleicht auf denen stehe. Also Facebook weiß sowas. Das ist nicht in so einem Datensatz drin, aber das wissen die natürlich auch.
Und das andere ist aber, es ist ja überall, ich glaube, das muss man an der Stelle auch ganz genau sagen. Es ist ja, also nicht überall, aber in vielen Webseiten sind ja Facebook-Like-Buttons oder Facebook-Kommentarfunktion oder sowas eingebettet. Und wenn man in Facebook eingeloggt ist und sich nicht ausgeloggt hat und mit dem Browser, in dem man in Facebook eingeloggt ist, auf so eine Seite kommt, dann weiß Facebook auch sofort, aha, der Richter ist jetzt auf der Seite. Das weiß ich, weil eingeloggt und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist der eine Weg, der andere Weg ist das Facebook Pixel. Also die haben sozusagen nicht nur die Like-Buttons, sondern ja auch noch sozusagen so eine Cookie-ähnliche Technik, über die sie auch sozusagen Third-Party-Tracking machen, also durch Auftrittsseiten verfolgen.
Aber warum sollte man das einbauen als Seitenbetreiber?
Weil Facebook selber auch ja ein Werbenetzwerk anbietet. Und beispielsweise man quasi, also nennt sich Audience-Network bei Facebook, sozusagen über dieses Audience-Network auch anzeigen, ja sozusagen wie Google quasi oder DoubleClick, sozusagen anzeigen, sich schalten lassen kann. Also dass da Facebook als Mitglied fungiert quasi.
Das heißt also, wenn man sich nicht ordentlich schützt und so in einem Tab Facebook offen hat oder vielleicht auch in seinem Browser so ein Mist, sag ich mal, abgelegt hat oder abgelegt bekommen hat und dann auf eine Porno-Seite geht, wo allerhand Like-Buttons eingebettet sind, ja, dann sind das schon sehr intime Informationen, die man da rausgeht. Und ich bezweifle, dass die Mehrheit der Nutzer das immer auf dem Schirm hat. Weil unbequeme Sachen blendet man ja auch gerne aus.
Jetzt noch eine ganze Kleinigkeit zum Audience-Network nachschieben. Wir kommen bestimmt später nochmal dazu. Es geht jetzt gerade nicht um Datensammeln, aber über dieses Audience-Network zum Beispiel bietet Facebook seinen Werbekunden eben auch an, Leute auch außerhalb von Facebook zu erreichen. Das heißt, wenn man über diese Custom-Audience-Geschichte guckt, okay, die Person XY, die ich schon in meiner Kunden-Datenbank habe, als Beauty-Produkthersteller oder was auch immer, und dann den Abgleich mache und die Person auch auf Facebook finde, bietet Facebook auch an, dass die gleiche Person auch außerhalb von Facebook gefunden wird und die Anzeigen zu sehen bekommt.
Also auf einer Webseite, die auch wiederum Facebook-Sachen integriert hat.
Genau, das muss der Webseitenbetreiber natürlich integriert haben.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, man liest immer wieder auch von Schattenprofilen. Könnt ihr kurz erklären, was das ist? Also das ist ja, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, ist das dann, also es gibt über mich ein Profil, obwohl ich gar nicht bei Facebook bin.
Ja, also man merkt das vielleicht, wenn man sich so ein Fake-Profil oder ein neues Profil bei Facebook anlegt, und dann bekommt man, wenn man nicht integriert eigentlich jeden Tag, so Spam-E-Mails, so ja XYZ wird sich total freuen, wenn du jetzt total aktiv bist auf Facebook. Und interessanterweise treffen diese E-Mails, wenn man eine E-Mail-Adresse benutzt, die man tatsächlich benutzt und auch Freunde mitgeteilt hat, erstaunlich oft den Bekanntenkreis. Und das kommt daher, da viele Menschen ihr Adressbuch bei Facebook hochladen oder es abgleichen. Das heißt, selbst wenn ich nicht bei Facebook bin, hat Facebook vielleicht über mich Informationen, mit wem ich befreundet bin, allein deshalb, weil andere Leute ihnen mitgeteilt haben, dass ich in ihrem Adressbuch bin. Oder aber, ja, Like-Button, andere Geschichten, das kann man auch alles zusammenfinden. Und das ist eben ein Schattenprofil, was ich nicht sehe. Also bei meiner Abfrage habe ich beispielsweise gesehen, welche Unternehmen meine E-Mail-Adresse abgeglichen haben. Ich kann aber nicht sehen, wer von meinen privaten Kontakten meine E-Mail-Adresse abgeglichen hat. Wobei ich das sehr gerne wüsste, weil ich die Leute doch schon gerne drauf ansprechen würde, dass ich das grundsätzlich nicht in Ordnung finde.
Ich habe ein selbes Erlebnis mit meiner Telefonnummer gehabt. Ich bin ja bei Facebook und ich bin auch ein bisschen aktiv, habe aber nie, nie meine Telefonnummer da angegeben. Und Facebook fragt mich bei jedem dritten oder vierten Login so, sag mal, ist nicht, dann erscheint hier eine Telefonnummer, die zufälligerweise meine Telefonnummer ist. Ist das nicht deine Telefonnummer? Und ich glaube, das kommt tatsächlich daher, dass Leute ihr Adressbuch hochgeladen haben, die mich in ihrem Adressbuch haben, mit denen ich auf Facebook befreundet bin. Und die auch mein Pseudonym kennen, unter dem ich bei Facebook unterwegs bin und das auch in ihrem Adressbuch habe. Und das ist natürlich so ein bisschen... Okay, die wissen... Würden die schon so weit gehen und sagen, die wissen alles?
Ich würde nicht sagen, die wissen alles, weil alleine sich ja da schon die Frage stellt, lässt sich überhaupt alles, lässt sich die Persönlichkeit, lässt sich das Leben, lässt sich die Identität wirklich in Datenform abgreifen. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen philosophische Frage. Aber natürlich gibt es auch Bereiche, wo die noch nicht reinschauen können, gerade wenn man sich irgendwie aktiv dagegen wehrt. Allerdings wissen die einfach sehr viel. Mir ist noch eingefallen, vielleicht noch mal kurz darauf hinzuweisen, auf den Daten, die sie auf Facebook sammeln, die schließen ja auch, machen sozusagen inferierte Schlüsse, die schließen aus deinem Verhalten auf bestimmte Dinge über dich beispielsweise. Also, die haben so, ich hab's mal andersrum versucht, ich hab mit diesem sozusagen Werbetargeting-Manager ein bisschen rumgespielt und mir angeguckt, was gibt's da überhaupt für Möglichkeiten. Und die zum Beispiel bieten ja auch an, dass man Leute ansprechen kann, gezielt, die in Fernbeziehung leben beispielsweise. Das musst du da gar nicht angegeben haben. Die sehen einfach, dass sozusagen die Person, mit der du in der Beziehung bist, das hast du vielleicht angegeben, sich an anderen Orten immer befindet als du. Und dann packen die dich in die Kategorie Fernbeziehung beispielsweise.
Christian, du wolltest noch zwei Sachen erzählen. Das eine ist Data Broker und das andere ist Patente.
Ja, genau. Die Patentgeschichte, das ist neulich mal ein bisschen rausgekommen oder es ist neulich ein bisschen Berichterstattung zu gewesen. Auch so geschlossene Dinge oder Dinge, die Facebook über seine Nutzerinnen und Nutzer schließt, ist ganz anschaulich geworden anhand eines Patents, das Facebook in den USA angemeldet hat, nämlich um Nutzerinnen und Nutzer anhand ihrer Daten in Klassen einzusortieren. Also sozusagen in welcher Region leben die oder loggen die sich ein? Wie viel Kohle haben die vielleicht? Was für Geräte benutzen die aufgrund dieser Datennutzerinnen und Nutzer in soziale Klassen einzuteilen? Es ist wirklich so simpel wie Oberschicht, Mittelklasse, Arbeitsklasse. Das ist der eine Punkt.
Ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen fassungslos, weil es gibt ja also, wenn man im Klischee glauben will, gibt es ja viele Menschen, die glauben, es gibt einen, die da oben und einen, wie hier unten. Und das, also natürlich kann man über Machtstrukturen und Politik da auch reden. Aber hier ist halt ein Fall, wo eine Firma ganz gezielt rangeht, genau dieses Weltbild, was man ja eigentlich nicht will, technisch darzustellen.
Weil es eben dabei hilft vielleicht, Werbekunden, die Leute anzusprechen, die man eben ansprechen möchte. Also will ich mein High-End-Produkt jetzt an Leute, die vielleicht in der Arbeiterklasse sind, nach diesem Modell vermarkten? Nee, die Effizienz wird gesteigert, wenn ich weiß, hier Oberklasse. Das ist die Logik dahinter?
Naja, nicht nur das. Es ist ja tatsächlich auch Vorschläge, dass man sagt, wie kann man solchen Leuten gute Produkte verkaufen, indem man armen Leuten den Aufstieg verspricht und reichen Leuten, indem man ihnen Dinge anbietet, die den Rückfall in das elende Proletariat verhindern. Und dann fällt dir darüber sozusagen in der Weiterentwicklung wieder eine weitere Spaltung der Gesellschaft statt.
Ja, im US-Werkampf wurden auch über 150, ich glaube, um die 150 Millionen Leuten wurden Anzeigen angezeigt, die zu Hass zwischen Gruppen aufrufen. Und das, finde ich, ist nochmal so ein ganz schwieriger Aspekt, wo du halt wirklich sagen kannst, ich fange an, Gruppen gegeneinander aufzuhetzen oder aufzuwiegeln. Und ich würde noch weitergehen, das ist gar nicht so um die Abbildung von Oberschicht oder Unterschicht, oder die, die Macht haben und die, die weniger Macht haben geht. Ich würde noch weitergehen und sagen, für die Zukunft sehe ich einfach ein Bild, dass diejenigen, die solche Informationen haben, auch ein Herrschaftswissen haben, weil wenn du weißt, wie Menschen ticken, wenn du weißt, wo ihre Schwachstellen sind, dann kannst du sie eben so ein bisschen nudgen, also so dahin schubsen, wo du sie haben willst.
Informationsasymmetrien, die letztendlich Machtasymmetrien sind, auf jeden Fall ist das nicht auch so.
Okay, darüber sprechen wir gleich. Wir haben jetzt geklärt, was ist der aktuelle Skandal, also was ist aktuell der Vorwurf gewesen. Wir haben weitergeklärt, was sind jetzt eigentlich diese Daten, die dieses, weil man sagt immer, sie sammeln alles und so, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen genau gehört, was das ist. Und dann reden wir in der nächsten halben Stunde nochmal ganz konzentriert darüber, was ist denn eigentlich im größeren Rahmen das Problem. Bevor wir das machen, aber eine kleine Musik von King Shee vom Album Red und zwar, das passt ja auch so ein bisschen zum Facebook, die immer die Weltherrschaft anspringen könnte, man meine Expansion heißt der Track. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück beim Chaosradio im Blumen. Nummer 244. Es geht heute darum, ob wir Facebook löschen oder nicht. Falls ihr das gemacht habt, also ein Facebook-Account wegen des aktuellen Skandals gelöscht, ruft an 0331 70 97 110 oder kommt vorbei im Fräulein Fritz in der Faltensteinstraße 47. Wir haben uns in der letzten halben Stunde darüber geredet, was für Daten Facebook über uns speichert. Und eine halbe Stunde, finde ich, ist viel Zeit. Aber jetzt gerade die Musik liefen, meint Engel und Katarschei. Ja, aber wir hätten da noch ein paar Geschichten zum Nachschieben, bevor wir über das nächste Thema reden. Welche sind das? Was wissen Sie denn noch über uns?
Ja, also das Bild vervollständigen sie dadurch, dass sie eben noch Daten von dritten Firmen aufkaufen oder dazu kaufen quasi. Sogenannte Data Broker ist eine eigene Branche, inzwischen Millionen, Milliarden Branche. Firmen, die nur darauf spezialisiert sind, aus allen möglichen Quellen Daten über Menschen zu sammeln und auch wieder in individuellen Profilen zusammenzuführen. Das geht irgendwie von dem Bonusprogramm Shopping-Daten über Kreditkartenbetreiber, Gesundheitsdaten.
Sie haben eine Karte dabei?
Zum Beispiel, genau. Die sind auch wiederum im Third-Party-Web-Tracking-Geschäft mit dabei. Also die haben selber eine große sozusagen Arbeit daran, möglichst umfassende Profile zu haben. Und von denen wiederum kauft Facebook noch Informationen dazu, führt das auch wieder zusammen mit dem, was sie schon wissen, über die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer anhand von Identifiern, E-Mail-Adresse, Bekundennummer, Payback-Nummer, irgendwas, damit das Bild noch vollständiger wird. Also damit auch beispielsweise nach dem offlineen Einkaufsverhalten getrackt werden kann.
Also, ich versuch das mal sozusagen an deinem Beispiel zu blöden. Also ich benutze immer für alles eine eigene E-Mail-Adresse. Aber ich habe eine Kundenkarte, wo ich mit einer E-Mail-Adresse angemeldet habe. Und die zeige ich jedes Mal vor, wenn ich in der offlineen Welt etwas einkaufe. Und das ist dieselbe E-Mail-Adresse, mit der ich mich bei Facebook angemeldet habe. Dann sagt Facebook also, lieber Kundenkartenbetreiber, ich kaufe mal bitte die Datensätze von dir.
Da sind wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Schritte zwischen. Da ist eben der Data Broker dazwischen sozusagen.
Es gibt Leute, die nichts anderes machen, außer Daten verkaufen. Und dann werden diese Datensätze und dann guckt Facebook, ah, E-Mail-Adresse passt über ein, super, kann ich jetzt...
Das ist einerseits, um das Profil sozusagen zu vervollständigen. Die andere Funktion, wofür das eingesetzt wird, ist, dass die sozusagen ihren Werbekunden dann wiederum sagen wollen, Erfolgsmeldung geben können, also Erfolgsmessung machen können. Also dann wirklich mit nachverfolgen. Der Typ, der auf deine Anzeige geklickt hat, die wir hier ihm gezeigt haben, der hat am Ende in den Laden gegangen und hat dein Scheißprodukt gekauft.
Der hat es nicht mit deinem Online-Job gekauft, aber der war dann...
Übrigens heute, aber hat Facebook oder gestern Abend hat Facebook bekanntgegeben, dass sie das runterfahren wollen oder einschränken wollen. Diese Zusammenarbeit mit dem Zufrieden.
Okay, wir reden gleich darüber, warum das jetzt gerade so sagen krass für Facebook, also krasser als sonst sozusagen ist, aber es ging noch um Staubkörner auf einer Linse und es ging noch um Filter. Also ging noch um Fotografie in sozialen Netzwerken.
Ja, also da hätten wir einmal so die Instagram-Fotoanalyse. Und zwar haben Forscher herausgefunden, dass man allein anhand der Wahl der Filter mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit voraussagen kann, ob ein Mensch eher depressiv ist oder nicht. Und falls ihr euch fragt, was man über euch so rausfinden kann, ja, wenn ihr einen eher so auf dem Blaufilter steht, wie beispielsweise ich oder den Graufilter oder Schwarz-Weiß und nicht so viele Menschen auf euren Bildern habt, dann würdet ihr wahrscheinlich da ins depressive Raster fallen. Und wenn ihr wenig Likes bekommt. Also so bei den Likes, ja, hätte ich vielleicht noch Glück, aber ich hab tatsächlich hauptsächlich eher traurige Bilder von wie Bürger in echt aussehen und so Sachen. Und ich liebe den Blaufilter.
Aber Menschen mit wenig Likes sind absoluten Zahlen? Oder Menschen, die sozusagen so und so viele Folle haben, die aber nicht deren Fotos liken?
Das weiß ich so im Detail nicht. Was aber auch noch interessant ist, Facebook hat noch so allerhand Patente angemeldet. Und man muss sich ja auch vor Augen führen, die machen unglaublich viele Studien mit ihren Daten und ich alles davon veröffentlich nie. Aber ein Patent, was sie angemeldet haben, geht um das Thema Staubkörner auf Fotolinsen. Also wir kennen das alle. Unser Smartphone ist klinisch rein und sauber, keine Bakterie weit und breit.
Ich putze auf gar keinen Fall gerade meine Kameralinsen.
Ja, also es gibt tatsächlich mittlerweile Analyse-Tools. Sie hat Facebook patentieren lassen, die feststellen können, ob zwei Fotos von derselben Kamera kommen, allein anhand der Analyse von Kratzern und Staubkörnern. Das heißt, wenn das selbe Foto oder ein Foto mit diesem Staubkorn-Indikator von zwei unterschiedlichen Geräten gepostet wurde, selbst wenn die Leute sonst keine Connection haben, kann man sagen, irgendwie müssen die zusammenhängen, weil die posten ein Bild vom selben Gerät.
Letztes Beispiel. Aber das ist wirklich mein Lieblingsbeispiel, für das, was Facebook selber sagt, was ihre Targeting tut, was sie mit den Daten machen können. Die sind dabei erwischt worden im vergangenen Jahr, wie sie in Australien bei einer Großbank Werbung gemacht haben, dafür gesagt haben, hier kommt zu uns, nutzt uns, um sozusagen Targeted Advertising zu machen. Denn wir sind die Besten. Bei uns könnt ihr nämlich, das war das, womit sie es gepitcht haben, emotional verletzliche Teenager identifizieren, ausfindig machen. Die könnt ihr in den Momenten erreichen, wenn sie sich, Zitat, am wertlosesten fühlen. Und dann kommt eure Werbung und ihr könnt ihnen den Boost geben, den sie brauchen sozusagen. Das war das Szenario, mit dem sie dafür geworben haben.
Aber hat dann Facebook gesagt, ja, das war nicht wir, das war nur der ausländische, australische...
Genau, sie haben am Ende gesagt, das war ein tragischer Einzelfall.
Ah, natürlich.
Einen haben wir noch. Und zwar hat das Datenteam von Facebook sich auch, sag ich mal, Systematiken von Beziehungen und Liebesgeschichten angeschaut. Und die haben beispielsweise festgestellt, dass man sehr genau sagen kann, wer mit wem wahrscheinlich verbandelt ist allein anhand der Freundeskreise. Weil man kennt das ja, wenn man länger zusammen ist, dann hat man immer mehr gemeinsame Freunde und gemeinsame Events. Und diese Dynamiken kann man sehr gut abbilden, selbst wenn jemand, sag ich mal, nicht offiziell auf Facebook seinen Beziehungsstatus bekanntgibt. Und am Tag der Trennung nimmt die Zahl der ausgetauschten Nachrichten Interaktionen im Schnitt um 225% zu.
Also dann nicht mit dem Ex-Partner, Partnerin, sondern mit allen anderen?
Nee, mit dem Ex-Partner. Also das ist wahrscheinlich dann so die Sache, du hast noch was von mir, letzte Konflikte, wie konntest du mir das antun? Und das eben, sag ich mal, in so einer ganz charakteristischen Weise.
Aber also umgedreht sagen, ich als Werbetreibender würde also sagen, also liebes Facebook, zeig doch mal den Leuten, die ihrem Partner gerade sehr viel mehr Nachrichten schreiben als sonst, meine Bar an.
Das Schwierige ist ja, wir reden einerseits über Potenziale, dessen was möglich ist, und wir wissen immer nicht genau, was machen sie dann tatsächlich oder was ist tatsächlich möglich. Einige oder viele der Sachen, über die wir gesprochen haben, sind bekannt, dass beispielsweise eben diese inferierten Schlüsse über Fernbeziehungen sozusagen, dass das weiter verraten wird. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob sie es anbieten oder ob es bekannt ist, dass sie es anbieten, dass man sozusagen frisch Getrennte ansprechen kann. Aber mich wundern wird es mir jetzt nicht.
Nee, also das geben sie natürlich nicht bekannt, obwohl theoretisch, also zumindest beim offiziellen Beziehungsstatus, ja, also, müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Aber ich glaube, an der Stelle ist noch eine Sache, für mich zu sagen, also das Problem, über das sie die ganze Zeit reden, das ist nicht Facebook weiß die Daten und gibt dann eure, also ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, die jetzt gerade von den Neuartigen Wohnraumkommfangs reden, sitzt nicht eure persönlichen Daten werden da weitergegeben, sondern Facebook ermöglicht es, zu sagen, also ich möchte folgenden Personen jetzt etwas zeigen. Und dann wird ein Profil gemacht, was halt möglicherweise ebenso genau ist. Also jemand, der arm ist, Dreck auf der Kameralinse hat und sich gerade getrennt hat, dem kann man sozusagen Werbung anzeigen.
In den USA gibt es auch so eine Kategorie, die nennt sich ethnische Affinität, wo dann sozusagen Hispanic American, African American und so weiter gezielt angesprochen oder ausdeutiert werden können für die Anzeigen.
Und es gab mal so einen kleinen Skandal, dass eine Zeit lang für zielgerichtete Werbung es möglich war, Leute, die Juden hassen, anzusprechen. Und es wurde dann öffentlich, danach hat Facebook natürlich die Kategorie gelöscht, aber es zeigt ja nur, was möglich ist und was in vielen Bereichen auch gemacht wird, wenn es keinen großen Skandal gibt.
Apropos, im natürlichen Verlauf einer Sendung müsste man jetzt sozusagen über die Stelle sprechen, warum halten denn Datenschützer und Aktivisten es für ein Problem, dass eine einzelne Stelle so viel über jemand weiß? Und es gibt dann eine sehr außerufernde Argumentation, die sagt, dass im Prinzip die Idee von Privatsphäre wichtig ist für die Gesellschaft, wie sie funktioniert. Ich würde das gerne heute nicht machen. Also weil wir haben das schon sehr oft gemacht und würde gerne auf die chaosradio.ccc.de verweisen, die Seite, wo die ganzen Podcasts von Chaosradio sind, wo man sich in einem beliebigen, wahrscheinlich am einfachsten ist, wenn man nach Vorratsdatenspeicherung sucht und sich da die Folgen mal anhört, da wurde das ja ausführlich erläutert. Und das Ding, was an diesem Skandal nämlich das Besondere ist ja, es gibt diese Argumentation, warum Privatsphäre eigentlich eher wichtig ist, schon sehr lange. Es ist sehr lange bekannt, was Facebook alles macht. Und es ist auch schon viele Leute, sowohl Institutionen als auch einzelne Aktivisten haben versucht dagegen vorzugehen. Bis jetzt ist nichts passiert. Jetzt ist es aber, dieses Mal scheint es so ein bisschen anders zu sein. Also Facebook scheint, wie soll man das sagen, unter Druck zu geraten oder sich mindestens bemüßigt sehen zu reagieren. Also ich fand es wirklich sehr beachtlich, dass der Mark Zuckerberg dann ein Interview gegeben hat, CNN gegenüber, was er normalerweise in der Art und Weise nicht macht. Also es gibt von ihm so Home-Stories und nette Geschichten und sowas, aber dass er sich aktiv zu einer, man könnte fast sagen Krise äußert, das passiert wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr selten. Und könnt ihr mir jetzt erklären, was ist dieses Mal anders? Also wie kommt es, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass Facebook sich ändert, aber wie kommt es denn, dass überhaupt zum ersten Mal so was bemerkbar ist, dass Facebook öffentlichen Druck zu spüren scheint?
Der Aktienkurs ist gefallen. Deshalb reagiert Zuckerberg.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, der Aktienkurs ist ja aus dem Grund gefallen, und zwar weil die Leute oder auch die Aktionäre langsam realisieren, dass die Regulierung am Horizont erscheint und nicht mehr so abstrakt durch die feuilletons wabert.
Aber was genau hat dazu geführt? Was hat dazu geführt, dass die Diskussion jetzt so geführt wird, so hart, dass man anscheinend denkt, okay, das können wir nicht einfach auslösen, da müssen wir regeln. Also ich kriege das nicht ganz gefasst. Also theoretisch ist mir das klar. Aber ich meine, ich habe mich ja schon oder auch Datenschutz und Aktivisten sozusagen regen sich schon sehr lange auf. Und dann, was ist jetzt der Unterschied?
Das Problem mit Datenschutz ist ja immer, Daten spürt man nicht, Daten fühlt man nicht, man spürt die Verletzung von Privatsphäre nicht. Wenn irgendwo jemand ein großes Profil über mich angelegt hat, so ja, weiß ich nicht davon. Also kann ja sein bei der NSA. Und in dem Fall ist es so, dass aus dieser abstrakten Gefahr, dass Datenschützer, Verbraucherschützer waren, ihr könnt anhand eurer Daten manipuliert werden, plötzlich ein konkreter Fall wird. Und plötzlich auch ein politischer Fall wird. Und das macht es natürlich auch nochmal. Also es ist ja eine Sache, ob mich jemand durchleuchtet, um mir halt die passenden Schuhe anzubieten oder vielleicht die passende Hardware. Und das ist was ganz anderes, wenn wir über eine Demokratie sprechen, wo sage ich mal so viele Daten über die einzelnen Wählerinnen und Wähler bei einem einzigen Unternehmen sind, dass man dann zielgerichtet versuchen kann, die öffentliche Meinung in eine Richtung zu drücken. Und wenn man das eben mit bezahlter Werbung macht, dann bedeutet das auch, derjenige, der die größten Datensammlungen hat, derjenige, der sich am wenigsten drum schert und derjenige, der das meiste Geld hat, in Kombination damit, kann die öffentliche Meinung beeinflussen. Und das ist sehr fundamental in einer Demokratie.
Aber irgendwann ist der Sack auch mal voll sozusagen, habe ich auch schon das Gefühl, dass das eine Rolle spielt. Also es ist ja nicht die erste Geschichte, sondern immer wieder das gleiche Muster. Entschuldigen, so ein bisschen zumindest, so verklausuliert entschuldigen. Eigentlich sind wir nicht schuld, aber trotzdem tut es uns leid, falls irgendwas falsch gelaufen ist. Wir ändern uns, wir arbeiten hart daran, dass wir es ändern. Das ist oft genug passiert. Und jetzt natürlich gerade in den USA, die Nachweise oder wirklich nachgewiesenen russischen Manipulationen im Rahmen des Wahlkampfes haben, glaube ich, zumindest in den USA das Klima nochmal deutlich verändert. Also dass da sozusagen russische Gruppen es möglich war, irgendwie im großen Stil Anzeigen zu kaufen, die mitgemischt haben im Wahlkampf, ohne dass es jemandem aufgefallen ist. Das hat, glaube ich, das Klima in den USA nochmal stark verändert. Aber ansonsten, was Katascha sagte, ich glaube nur, es addiert sich irgendwann auf. Und jetzt steht auch die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung vor der Tür.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was ich hier interessant finde, ist, wir sind ja fast schon wieder jetzt mit dieser Sendung am Ende des News Cycles. Die Geschichte ist so ungefähr zwei Wochen an und es ist fast schon so, also wir machen das, weil wir es im Chaosradio immer so machen, dass wir eine Sache sehr ausführlich erklären, damit man also nicht nur jetzt gerade, sondern auch in einem Jahr noch, weil man, was war denn damals eigentlich los, kann man das sozusagen hier nochmal genau nachhören. Aber ich frage mich trotzdem, wie lange wird das halten? Und wir können jetzt mal über die verschiedenen, also Konsequenzen sprechen, die das haben könnte, möchte ich wirklich so sagen, Konjunktur. Wir sprechen gleich noch über etwas, was Datenschutzgrundverordnung heißt. Aber zum ersten ist es heute an mir vorbeigeflogen. Ich habe leider nicht gelesen, was genau die Argumentation ist, aber es gibt anscheinend die Idee, Facebook zu verstaatlichen.
Ja, also ich glaube, nach Snowden und der ganzen Geschichten auch in Deutschland, die wir über unsere Geheimdienste und staatliche Behörden wissen, ist glaube ich recht klar, dass man als Datenschützer, als Verbraucherschützer kein staatliches soziales Netzwerk haben möchte. Weil da, wo ein Trog ist, da kommen die Schweine, sagt man ja so schön. Und ja, in dem Fall, wo Daten sind, da entstehen Stellenbegehrlichkeiten. Kann ich noch von abraten.
Okay, ich möchte dann jetzt sagen, dass jetzt spalten. Das eine ist, es gibt große zentral geführte soziale Plattformen. Wie können die möglicherweise betrieben werden, so dass man sagt, okay. Und das andere ist, gibt es Alternative? Wie könnt ihr aussehen? Ich würde zu sagen, wirklich gerne erst bei diesem einen Denken. Ich muss zwar letztens halt immer wieder daran denken, dass es ja ganz früher mal ein soziales Netzwerk gab, das hieß MySpace. Und da kann ich heutzutage kaum einer erinnern. Und das war aber auch, es gab eine Zeit, da war das also groß. Das war nie so groß wie Facebook, aber es war halt groß und gefühlt tatsächlich überall und gekommen, um zu bleiben. Und das war wirklich so in einem Halbjahreszeitraum, würde ich sagen, wo es auf einmal so krass war. Moment, was wir es denn eigentlich aus? Hm, sehr seltsam. So, Facebook. Also mal ausgehend davon, dass das möglicherweise nicht verschwindet jetzt so. Was sind denn für Ideen? Also wird jetzt so, es gibt das Schlagwort der Regulierung. Was, wie will man das denn regulieren? Ich hab neulich mit Tilo Weichert gesprochen, ehemaliger Datenschützer in Schleswig-Holstein. Der hat ja Facebook auch mal verklagt. Da ist ja nie so richtig viel passiert. Also gab es immer so ein kleines News-Ding, und dann war es aber wieder... Was gibt es denn da jetzt für andere Ideen, wie man mit Facebook umgehen kann?
Na ja, also ich glaube, wir müssen in unserer Gesellschaft einfach auch eine Debatte darüber führen, wie weit die Durchleuchtungen für ökonomische oder andere Interessen des menschlichen Lebens gehen darf und wo vielleicht auch eine rote Linie ist. Also um mal ganz niedrigschwellige Regulierungen anzusprechen, wir müssen einfach darüber sprechen, was für Daten überhaupt erhoben werden dürfen, was für Daten überhaupt verwertet werden dürfen. Und vor allem, ob es nicht auch so etwas wie Löschfristen geben sollte für bestimmte Daten. Also als ich mein Datenprofil bei Facebook abgerufen habe, da ist mir auch klar geworden, warum keine Löschfristen in den Facebook-AGB genannt sind. Man löscht einfach Daten nicht, mit denen man Gewinn generieren kann.
Es gibt ein grundsätzliches Problem. Also es gibt ja anscheinend einen großen Bedarf daran, an einem sozialen Netzwerk teilzunehmen. Also diese Milliarden User, die Facebook da hat, sind ja nicht dadurch zu erklären, dass irgendjemand die dahin geprügelt hat, sondern es gibt ja anscheinend so eine Lust daran, da zu sein. Und da gibt es ja zwei Wege, wie so eine Plattform, die betrieben wird, Geld verdienen kann. Das eine ist halt monatlich ein Zehner oder beliebiger Beitrag sozusagen, der immer Leuten so teuer sein wird. Der andere ist, wir machen das genau über dieses Modell. Also wir spielen Werbung aus. Wenn man Werbung ausspielen muss, muss man wissen, wie macht man die hin? Also ist, stellt du jetzt auch das grundsätzliche Modell in Frage?
Ja, also wie der Zufall das will, habe ich meine Abschlussarbeit über die Markteintrittschancen von dezentralen sozialen Netzwerken an der Uni Hamburg geschrieben und tatsächlich denke ich, es gibt noch mehr Modelle. Also wir sollten halt fleißig machen.
Nein, nein, Moment, aber darüber wollen wir später sprechen. Die Frage ist ja, eine zentrale Plattform, die ein soziales Netzwerk ist, die kann ja anders nicht betrieben werden, oder?
Ich glaube aber, es ist ein Mythos, dass Werbung heutzutage nur aufgrund dieser krassen umfassenden Datensammlung passieren kann. Also es gäbe ja auch Modelle, wo man sagen könnte, also ich sage jetzt nicht, dass das die Lösung ist, aber ich glaube schon, dass es Werbemodelle gäbe, die nicht ganz so invasiv sind, die beispielsweise, weiß ich nicht, also alleine der Ort, ich will jetzt nur mal ein bisschen Gedanken spielen. Also vielleicht Google wirbt viel oder nutzt viel beispielsweise die Geolokationen in der Suche Anzeigen zu spezialisieren.
Fragt mich alle 5 Minuten, darf ich deinen Ort verwenden?
Ja, aber ich meine, vielleicht könnte man auch einfach mal sagen, ok, bestimmte Informationen nicht oder sozusagen Facebook reißt sich einfach ein bisschen zusammen und versucht nicht dieses creepy alles wissende Ding zusammen zu sein, sondern sagt einfach ok, hey Leute, das ist das Modell, wir finanzieren uns Überwerbung und wir geben euch aber die Möglichkeit, einfach ein bisschen selber mit zu bestimmen, wir informieren euch darüber, was passiert. Problem ist nur, das Geschäftsmodell basiert eben derzeit darauf, dass die Nutzer im Unklaren bleiben und im Dunkeln tappen. Also Facebook arbeitet am Eck massiv daran, dass Nutzerinnen und Nutzer nicht Bescheid wissen darüber, was passiert eigentlich mit den Daten. Also ich würde sagen, Werbung kann man drüber sprechen, fände ich nicht geil. Ich fände andere Modelle gut. Ich würde auch tatsächlich über öffentlich-rechtliche Finanzierung sprechen. Es gibt ja auch noch staatlich-gemeinschaftlich finanzierte Modelle, die nicht heißen, der Staat betreibt es, sondern die noch dazwischen sind.
Ja, wobei ich da immer sagen würde, natürlich kann man das machen, aber dann stelle ich mir mal vor, in Deutschland passiert ein Attentat, da werden die Begehrlichkeiten groß sein, die gesetzlichen Regelungen von Zugriffsbefugnissen ganz schnell wieder aufzuweichen. Wir hatten uns ja vorhin schon drüber unterhalten, eigentlich wäre ja geil, wenn das von einer unabhängigen, gemeinnützigen Stelle betrieben wird, eine Stiftung beispielsweise, wo ich sagen kann, diese Woche wieder geiler Service, überweise ich mal einen Zehner und gut ist.
Das Argument, das an der Stelle immer dagegen kommt, ist ja, Facebook ist ja nur so toll, nur so berühmt geworden oder nur so viel genutzt geworden, weil sie so innovativ sind, weil sie sozusagen, das könnte staatlicherseits oder sozusagen durch eine nicht kapitalgetriebene Finanzierung oder ein nicht kapitalgetriebenes Modell gar nicht, wäre niemand in der Lage, so innovativ zu sein. Das ist ein Gegenargument, das an der Stelle immer kommt. Ich sehe das nicht so. Ich glaube, man könnte, ich finde Facebook auch ohnehin nicht mehr besonders innovativ, aber...
Also davon abgesehen, das Elternnetzwerk, wie es ja manchmal auch genannt wird. Aber noch mal gefragt, es gibt diese Datenschutzgrundverordnung. Also ein Gesetz, ein EU-Gesetz, das demnächst kommt und in dieser Diskussion, wenn man es ein bisschen verfolgert, war das immer so, ja, das kann ja wirklich was helfen. Und jetzt ist es ja, wie ich gerade schon versucht habe, sozusagen zu erinnern, ist es mit Datenschutzgesetzen nicht so, dass die bis jetzt besonders wirksam waren? Was ist denn bei der DSGVO anders?
Also es gibt tatsächlich ja die Fälle. In Spanien ist neulich eine hohe, vermeintlich hohe Strafe gegen Facebook verhangen worden. Genau aufgrund intransparenter Datensammlung. Nutzerinnen und Nutzer wussten nicht Bescheid. Oder das war der Vorwurf eben über das, was mit ihren Daten passiert, wie die für Werbung verwendet werden. Und die haben eine Strafe von einer Million Euro verhangen. Die französische Datenschutzbehörde hat neulich die Höchststrafe von 150.000 Euro verhangen. Das ist natürlich so die große Hoffnung, die jetzt mit der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung mitschwingt, dass Datenschutzbehörden endlich Sanktionsmöglichkeiten bekommen, die sozusagen der gesellschaftlichen Bedeutung des Datenschutzes auch gerecht werden, bis zu 4% des weltweiten Umsatzes.
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Also 4% des Umsatzes des Konzerns. Also nicht irgendwie die Facebook-Filiale, die hier in Irland gegründet wurde, oder das Büro, das in Hamburg sitzt, sondern weltweit 4%.
Das ist so die Hoffnung.
Das so ungefähr geht in Richtung einer Milliarde, würde ich sagen.
Aber haltet ihr das für realistisch? Also, dass das auch um und durchgesetzt wird?
Das hängt echt stark von den Datenschutzbehörden ab. Also bislang auch im Rahmen dieser Android-Telefondaten, die gerade sozusagen, das was jetzt gerade noch letzte Woche rausgekommen ist, Facebook greift oder hat lange Zeit auch die Telefonhistorie von Android-Telefonen mit abgegriffen, weil Google da sloppy war, was die Erlaubnisse, App-Erlaubnisse anging. Da sind jetzt auch wieder nur so, ja, ist fraglich, ob das vereinbar ist, so die Äußerung von Datenschutzbehörden geht nicht, steht im Widerspruch zu und nicht, knallharte Aussage, das ist illegal und das werden wir ahnden, wenn wir die Möglichkeiten dazu endlich haben. Ich kann nur hoffen, dass die Datenschutzbehörden das dann tun. Dafür wiederum muss man auch dazu sagen, müssen die entsprechend ausgestattet sein. Die schreien alle auf, dass sie nicht genug Mittel und sowieso auch nicht die technischen Möglichkeiten haben, dann tatsächlich ihrer Aufgabe gerecht zu werden. Das ist noch so ein anderes Thema.
Also, hm, aber ist das denn, hm, also ich würde ja vermuten, es wird sich tatsächlich, also das ist ja eine EU-Gesetz. Da wird sich schon in irgendeinem Land mal eine Datenschutzbehörde finden, die sagt, so Leute, das war's. Schön mal hier die vier Prozent über den Tisch gelegt. Und dann ist ja die Frage, wie jeder darauf reagiert wird. Es gibt ja in der DSGVO auch dieses Marktortprinzip. Also das jetzt sozusagen wirklich, wenn sich Facebook an Nutzerinnen und Nutzer in Deutschland richtet, dann ist es auch hier sozusagen relevant.
Ja, das ist immens wichtig, weil momentan haben ja ganz viele große Konzerne, die sich durch ein Geschäftsmodell basierend auf Datensammeln gegründet haben. Die haben ihre EU-Filiale in Irland. Und Irland ist so eine Art Datenoase im Vergleich zu Steueroasen. Vielleicht Datenoase, wo es nicht nur besonders laxe Datenschutzgesetze gibt, sondern eine sehr laxe Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörde. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Problem. Also diese vereinzelte Gesetzgebung bisher, wenn man gegen einen Konzern vor Gericht ziehen will. Also mein ganz konkretes Beispiel Max Schremms hatte wirklich einen epischen Rechtsfeld gegen Facebook geführt. Das ist der junge Mann, von dem ich eben schon erzählt habe, der seine 1222 PDF-Seiten von Facebook rausgezogen hat. Und der wollte Facebook verklagen und musste dann vor Irland, vor Gericht gehen und hat dann nach einem Anwalt gesucht. Und kein auf Datenschutz spezialisierter Anwalt wollte ihn vertreten, weil die natürlich alle, sage ich mal größere Kunden aus diesem Bereich der Datensammlung haben und dann natürlich trotz vielen Spendengeldern keine Lust hatten, ihn zu vertreten. Und am Ende hatte er einen Anwalt, der eigentlich auf Asylrecht spezialisiert war. Und sie haben ihm dann nachher auf Zetteln vorgeschrieben, was er da sagen soll.
Aber teilt ihr trotzdem diesen moderaten Optimismus, was die Datenschutz-Konfortung angeht? Oder sagt ihr, egal, weil in drei Wochen ist sowieso alles wieder wie es vorher war?
Ja, also ich glaube, diese 4% sind schon eine Ansage. Ich glaube, das ist auch die einzige Sprache, die Unternehmen vor allem, sage ich mal, Shareholder-Value maximierend orientierte Unternehmen letztendlich verstehen und auch Datenschutzbeauftragte aus Unternehmen, von denen hört man immer wieder, endlich kann ich mal meine Sachen durchargumentieren und werde auch gehört und werde auch ernst genommen. Nicht nach dem Motto, da müssen wir so ein bisschen, da können wir eventuell mit werben, sondern wenn ihr das nicht macht, dann kann das bis an die Existenzgrundlage des Unternehmens gehen. Natürlich, wie das am Ende ausgelegt wird, das werden wir sehen, aber da kann man ja im schlimmsten Fall hoffen, dass es trotzdem besser wird als bisher. Und das wird es allemal.
Also ich glaube, wir können uns jetzt schon darauf einstellen, dass dann die Gerichtsverfahren losgehen erst mal und dass es dann noch ein paar Jahre dauern wird, bis dann tatsächlich Klarheit herrscht.
Na gut, dann gucken wir mal, was dann passiert und reden jetzt in der nächsten halben Stunde gleich nochmal über die anderen möglichen Alternativen. Vorher gibt es noch einmal NerdNews geschrieben von Mo, vorgetragen von Helena und danach Musik von KingShi, Blue Elephant heißt sie, danach Nachricht mit einem Verkehr.
Die Transportverschlüsselung TLS 1.3, die Datenpakete im Internet verschlüsselt, ist als Standard der Internet Engineering Taskforce IETF verabschiedet worden. Sie bringt modernere Verschlüsselungen. Außerdem wird schon der Verbindungsaufbau kryptographisch gesichert. Behörden, Banken und Betreiber von Rechenzentren forderten bis zuletzt Nachschlüssel, konnten sich aber nicht durchsetzen. Daher kündigten sie an, sich beim European Telecom Standards Institute für einen Gegenstandard einzusetzen, der ihren Wünschen entspricht. Forscher haben in der Bitcoin-Blockchain an mehreren Stellen illegale Inhalte entdeckt, die von Nutzern eingeschleust wurden. Aufgrund des Funktionsprinzips der Blockchain werden die mehr als 1600 Inhalte weltweit verteilt und können nicht mehr gelöscht werden. Unter den Inhalten seien zwei Linklisten, die auf Seiten mit dokumentiertem Kindesmissbrauch verweisen. Außerdem ein Bild, das Kindesmissbrauch zeige und damit in den meisten Staaten illegal sei. Damit dürfte es in diesen Ländern also illegal sein, die Bitcoin-Blockchain abzuspeichern. Das könnte die gesamte Kryptowährung gefährden, denn zum Schürfen ist es notwendig, die Datenbank herunterzuladen. Auch andere Kryptowährungen setzen auf die Blockchain-Technik und sind ebenfalls angreifbar. Der Chatdienst Telegram ist vom obersten Gericht der Russischen Föderation verurteilt worden, mit dem Inlandsgeheimdienst FSB zusammenzuarbeiten. Der FSB verlangt von den Telegram-Betreibern Hilfe bei der Entschlüsselung von Chats. Telegram wurde vom Gericht eine Frist gesetzt, der Aufforderung des Geheimdienstes Folge zu leisten, sonst drohe die Sperrung, meldete die Deutsche Welle. Telegram-CEO Pavel Durov erklärte auf Twitter, die Sperrdrohung werde keine Früchte tragen.
Sein Dienst werde für Freiheit und Privatsphäre stehen.
Darf ich? Feind!
Beste Musik mit uns.
Anti-Loken-Gang.
Diesen Sonntag wieder. Auf Fritz.
Es ist kurz nach halb 12.
Mit Benedikt Wenck. Bundesfamilienministerin Giffey will Angestellte in der Pflege und der Erziehung besser bezahlen. Das sagte sie heute bei Besuchen in einem Seniorenstift in Brandenburg und einer Kita in Berlin.
Bei Pflegerinnen und Pflegern denkt sie auch über eine kostenlose Ausbildung und eine bessere Familienfreundlichkeit des Jobs nach. Einen höheren Lohn will Giffey auch bei Erzieherinnen und Erziehern. Wegen des religiösen Mobbings an manchen Schulen fordern einige Zuwandererverbände einen Neuanfang in der Islampolitik. Der Präsident der Bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft der Immigrantenverbände in Deutschland hat sich etwa dazu geäußert, er fordert, dass Parteien, Kirchen und Stiftungen die Zusammenarbeit mit Vertretern des politischen Islams einstellen. Außerdem hat er davor gewarnt, dass es immer mehr Kinder aus muslimischen Elternhäusern gäbe, die andere Schüler angriffen und beschimpften, weil diese nicht an Allah glaubten. Beim US-Sportausrüster Under Armour gab es einen Hackerangriff, und zwar auf die App MyFitnessPal. Etwa 150 Millionen Konten seien betroffen. An der Armour geht davon aus, dass Nutzernamen, Mailadressen und Passwörter geklaut wurden. Kreditkartendaten oder Sozialversicherungsnummern sollen nicht betroffen sein. Die Eisbären haben ihr erstes Play-off-Halbfinalspiel in der Deutschen Eishockeyliga gewonnen. Gegen Nürnberg stand es am Ende 5 zu 1. Alba Berlin hatte in einem Nachholspiel der Basketball-Bundesliga mit 98 zu 68 in Erfurt gewonnen. Alba bleibt damit weiter tabellens weiter. Und in der Handball-Bundesliga haben die Füchse Berlin in Stuttgart unentschieden gespielt mit 24 zu 24. In Berlin Spandau 4 und Marzahn 5 Grad, Ludwigsfelde 3, Falkensee und Königsrösterhausen 4, Lindenberg 5 Grad. Nachts bleibt es erstmal überwiegend trocken mit lockeren Wolken, bis am Morgen dann stellenweise Nebel aufkommt.
Die Temperaturen sinken auf minus 3 bis 0 Grad.
Am Karfreitag dann generell eher schön. Die Sonne scheint auch mal länger, dazu milde Temperaturen von 8 bis 13 Grad. Der Rest der Feiertage dann eher wechselhaft und kühler, bis am Ostermontag wieder die Sonne rauskommt. Auf der B 97 Dresden, Heuerswerda. Zwischen Bernsdorf und Heuerswerda Neidahr in beiden Richtungen, da gibt es einen Wildunfall und außerdem befinden sich noch Wildschweine auf der Fahrbahn. Und noch ein genereller Witterungshinweis.
In Berlin und Brandenburg muss in der Nacht mit Glätte auf Straßen und Wegen gerechnet werden.
Bitte fahrt vorsichtig, und wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz im Live- oder Musikstream hören wollt, dann geht doch mal auf fritz.de slash Streambox.
Heute das Chaosradio im Blue Moon live aus dem Fräulein Fritz in der Frankensteinstraße 47. Ihr könntet noch vorbeikommen, wenn ihr gerade in der Nähe im schlesischen Tor seid und mal live sehen wollt, wie wir darüber reden, ob man ein gewisses soziales Netzwerk mit einem blauen Logo abschaffen können sollte. Dann könnt ihr das machen oder 0331 70 97 110 anrufen, falls ihr noch Fragen habt. Das hat zum Beispiel nämlich Christine geschrieben auf der Studio Message, die ihr auch machen könnt, dass sie das Facebook-Thema und den damit verbundenen Skandal noch gar nicht so wirklich verstanden hat. Und jetzt hier in der Sendung erst mitbekommen hat, was da alles dahinter steckt. Falls also noch Fragen offen sind, könnt ihr gerne die noch stellen unter 0331 70 97 110. Und auch hier die Dinge beobachten, die in der Sendung so vor sich gehen, zum Beispiel verschwinden dann auf seltsame Art und Weise Studio-Gäste. Zu Gast sind heute hier Katharina Nocun und Ingo Dachwitz von Netzpolitik Org, die jetzt gerade während der Nachrichten uns abhandengekommen sind. Wir spielen also jetzt eine kleine Musik und dann sind wir gleich wieder da hier im Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Ja, live ist das Chaosradio aus dem Fräulein Fritz und jetzt wieder auch hier zu Gast, die sie gerade ferdinisierten Ingo und Katascha. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück.
Ich kann auch nur empfehlen, hier mal persönlich vorbeizukommen, sonst nehme ich direkt die Bar.
Ja, da kann man schon mal auch versacken. So, wir haben aber noch viel zu tun der letzten halben Stunde. Wir wollten tatsächlich noch mal drüber reden, was man, wenn man jetzt denkt, so soziale Netzwerke, die großen zentralen Plattformen vielleicht nicht so doll. Was könnte man denn da noch machen? Könnte man da noch mal was machen? Also ich meine, Katarzya hat ja vorhin was von dezentralen Netzwerken erzählt, die unter Umständen eine Lösung sein könnten.
Ja, also es gibt ja unterschiedliche Formen, wie man Netzwerke denken kann. Einerseits gibt es dann so einen zentralen Anbieter, bei dem alles läuft, so wie Facebook. Und dann kann man sich aber auch natürlich vorstellen, ein dezentrales Netzwerk zu machen oder eine Mischform dazwischen, dass es so zumindest verschiedene Knotenpunkte gibt, die den Dienst anbieten. Das hat natürlich auch den Vorteil wie beim Internet, sag ich mal. Wenn ein Knoten ausfällt, dann kommt man immer noch irgendwo ans Ziel. Und dezentrale soziale Netzwerke wurden bekannt, oder, sag ich mal, einem größeren Publikum bekannt, als, ich glaube, im Jahr 2010 war das, diaspora an den Start geht. Und das war so eine Idee von ein paar Studenten, die gesagt haben, wir finden es nicht in Ordnung, was Facebook macht, damals schon. Und die haben gesagt, wir wollen ein datenschutzfreundliches Netzwerk, aber wir sehen auch die Probleme in dieser zentralisierten Struktur. Das heißt, wir wollen ein dezentrales, soziales Netzwerk. Das heißt, es ist freie Software. Und jemand, der sagt, ich möchte jetzt selber, sag ich mal, so einen einzelnen Datenknotenpunkt von diesem Netzwerk aufmachen, der kann sich einfach die Software installieren und quasi mit an diesem sozialen Netzwerk teilnehmen. Das heißt, ich kann auch unter Umständen entscheiden, ich möchte selber so ein Datenknotenpunkt werden. Und kann dann viel selbstbestimmter darüber entscheiden, was, wo, wie gespeichert, verwertet wird.
Naja, aber da muss man ja sagen, mit den digitalen sozialen Netzwerken, also gerade Diaspora ist ein schönes Beispiel, also nicht schön, aber sozusagen ein gutes Beispiel, ist es ja wie mit dem Datenschutz. Das ist eine total nette Idee, aber das ist ja bis jetzt, also grandioser scheitern kann man ja fast gar nicht.
Ja, und deshalb habe ich auch meine Abschlussarbeit drüber geschrieben, weil ich mich natürlich gefragt habe, hey, das ist so eine geile Idee, warum machen da nicht mehr Leute mit? Und ein Grundproblem, was wir bei Kommunikationsnetzwerken aller Art haben, ist der Netzwerkeffekt. Der Netzwerkeffekt besagt, dass ich nicht, also vereinfacht gesagt, ich gehe nicht zu dem Netzwerk, was die geilsten AGB hat, oder die geilsten Datenschutzbestimmungen, sondern ich gehe einfach zu dem Netzwerk, wo die meisten Leute sind. Und es gibt nicht nur einen globalen Netzwerkeffekt, weil mich interessiert ja herzlich wenig, welches Netzwerk die meisten Kontakte insgesamt hat, beispielsweise in China, sondern mich interessiert, was das meist benutzte Netzwerk in meinem Freundeskreis ist. Das heißt, wenn die meisten Leute in meinem Freundeskreis WhatsApp nutzen, oder wenn die meisten Leute in meinem Freundeskreis Facebook nutzen und ich keine Möglichkeit habe, mit einem anderen Dienst mit diesen Accounts zu kommunizieren, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß, dass ich auch diesen Netzwerken beintreten will. Das wäre vergleichbar mit einer Situation, als wenn man beispielsweise von einer GMX-E-Mail-Adresse immer nur E-Mails an alle anderen GMX-E-Mail-Adressen schreiben könnte und nicht beispielsweise zu Posteo oder Mailbox oder als Vornamenachnahme. Genau. Und das ist ein grundsätzliches Problem, was wir eben bei sozialen Netzwerken haben. Wir haben keine standardisierte Sprache, kein standardisiertes Protokollschnittstell, die eben sicherstellt, dass ich mit einem Diaspora-Account nach wie vor mit meinen Leuten auf Facebook in Kontakt bleiben kann.
Naja, aber wie gesagt, das sind ja die Ideen, die aber, also wie sollen die umgesetzt werden? Also ich sehe eigentlich, wenn ich drüber nachdenke, zwei, also gerade zwei große Modelle. Das eine ist ja so eine große Dezentralität, also es wird schon irgendwie von Firmen oder Institutionen betrieben, aber es gibt mehr als nur einen Server-Park, oder andersrum nochmal von vorne. Also Facebook ist ja, wenn man so will, ein großer Computer, ist ja technisch nicht, aber sozusagen ist ein zentraler Anbieter, wo das alles passiert. Und die eine Idee, die du hattest, war ja sozusagen, es gibt das immer noch, dass das sozusagen zentral relativ organisiert wird, aber dann schon so ein bisschen verteilt.
Ja, also distributed quasi. Also was du zumindest sagen kannst, ich hab zumindest die Wahl zwischen A und B.
Ja, und das andere ist, also mal extrem ausprobiert, jeder kann selber sozusagen so ein kleines Netzwerk bei sich betreiben, man kann aber mit ganzen vielen anderen kleinen Netzwerken da sind. Also beim zweiten Fall, da ist ja das Problem, wer soll das denn machen? Ich glaube, zum Beispiel Mail Server ist ja so was. Theoretisch kann ja jeder seinen eigenen Mail Server betreiben. Das ist nur, wenn man nicht Bock hat, mit dem Thema sich zu beschäftigen, ist das ja unfassbar kompliziert. Also einen Rechner so aufzusetzen, dass da ein Mail Server draufläuft, ist Hexenwerk. Also für mich auch. Und dann ist ja die Frage, gibt es Ideen, wie man dahin kommt, dass wirklich jeder so eine kleine Box in seinen Schreibtisch stellen kann und sagt so hier, das ist mein Knotenpunkt, wo meine Daten drauf sind?
Ja, es gibt unterschiedliche Modelle. Es gibt mittlerweile auch einzelne Projekte, die beispielsweise so eine Freedom Box anbieten. Das ist so eine Box, wo ganz viele Dienste vorinstalliert sind, wo ich quasi Plug and Play machen kann. Ich brauche kein großes technisches Wissen, um das selbst bei mir einzustöpseln. Ich glaube aber tatsächlich, dass trotzdem immer noch die Hürde für die meisten Menschen ziemlich hoch ist. Und ich fände es persönlich schon eine Verbesserung, wenn ich zumindest die Möglichkeit hätte, zwischen Anbieter A und Anbieter B zu entscheiden. Sprich, ich habe ja bei der E-Mail Adresse auch die Wahl, ob ich zu Google Mail gehe oder vielleicht zu einem datenschutzfreundlichen Anbieter. Und zumindest diese Wahl zu haben, wäre schon eine Verbesserung.
Ich glaube, die Grundvoraussetzung muss erst mal eben geschaffen werden, dass auch sozusagen unterschiedliche, vielleicht sogar unterschiedliche Netzwerkanbieter oder Plattformanbieter miteinander kommunizieren können. Also Plattform-Interoperabilität ist sozusagen das politische Begriff dahinter. Also sozusagen Standards dafür entwickeln, dass ich von einer Plattform mit Leuten auf einer anderen Plattform kommunizieren kann, damit ich eben nicht, nur weil ich jetzt zu einer datenschutzfreundlicheren Alternative wechsle, sofort mein halbes Sozialleben verliere, weil das noch auf der anderen Plattform hängt. Diese Grundvoraussetzung muss überhaupt erst mal geschaffen werden, dass es einen technischen Standard dafür gibt.
Aber diese Datenschutzgrundfordern, über die wir schon gesprochen haben, die fordert ja unter anderem auch, dass man in Zukunft seine Daten jederzeit runterladen kann in einem maschinenläsbaren Format. Also da wäre ja zumindest sozusagen der Umzug gewährleistet. Ich könnte dann sagen, ich mache bei Netzwerk A, ladet man meine Daten runter, gehe zu Netzwerk B, kann die da wieder hochladen, weil die bestimmt auch Interesse daran haben, dass man die einliest und sowas. Ich glaube, dass über diesen Weg...
Das ist eine Voraussetzung, das hilft einem nur nichts, wenn man dann trotzdem allein ist auf dem neuen Netzwerk quasi. Dann habe ich dann meine Daten mitgenommen quasi und hänge dann trotzdem alleine auf dem anderen Netzwerk. Also, ich meine, technisch ist es ja irgendwie gelungen, dass ich von unterschiedlichen E-Mail-Anbietern mit unterschiedlichen E-Mail-Anbietern untereinander miteinander kommunizieren können. Oder eben auch unterschiedliche Telefonnetze sozusagen zusammengeschaltet werden. Dass ich nicht als Telekom-Kunde nur mit Telekom-Kunden telefonieren kann. Und meine Hoffnung wäre, dass wenn es Standards dafür gäbe, dass Plattformen miteinander kommunizieren können, dass das dann es befeuern würde überhaupt erst mal, dass weitere Alternativen entwickelt werden.
Aber ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn man das jetzt so betrachtet, das klingt irgendwie total einleuchtend, wenn man denkt, ja, das Netzwerk ist so groß, dann müsste ich besser verteilen. Aber die, so viele Sachen, die neu sind, die lassen sich ja dann in diesem Bereich gar nicht so einordnen. Also zum Beispiel kann ich mir, also ich kann mir theoretisch vorstellen, okay, es gibt so was anderes, das ist so ähnlich wie Facebook und da kann man dann irgendwie miteinander reden. Aber zum Beispiel zwischen Snapchat und Facebook eine Dateninteroperabilität wäre ja Quatsch sozusagen, weil es sind ja völlig verschiedene Ansätze von was ich mit meinem neuartigen Grundfunkumfangsgerät mache.
Ja, also man müsste sich schon zusammensetzen mit unterschiedlichen Anbietern und sagen, das sind die, sag ich mal, Features, die wir haben und da brauchen wir eben Standard. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Aushandlungsprozess, ja. Und da darf man sich nichts vormachen. Das wird auch natürlich auch mit Arbeit verbunden sein. Aber ich glaube, also um mal eine historische Anekdote zu bringen, der Erfinder des Protokolls für E-Mail-Anhänge hat mal gesagt, wenn wir heute, in der heutigen Zeit, mit dieser Zentralisierung, die wir haben in allen Bereichen, wenn heute jemand das Protokoll für E-Mail erfinden würde, dann hätten wir einen de facto E-Mail-Anbieter der Welt. Weil niemand würde das als offenen Standard platzieren wollen. Alle würden sagen, ich möchte, dass alle bitte gefälligst zu mir gehen. Da gibt es diese Fahrtabhängigkeiten. Ich glaube, historisch haben wir da den richtigen Zeitpunkt verpasst. Das hätte man viel früher angehen müssen. Trotzdem bin ich überzeugt davon, man darf nicht aufhören, da in die Richtung zu gehen. Wenn man sagt, das ist so ein Riesenproblem mit Facebook, wie das jetzt momentan funktioniert, und das ist eine Machtkonzentration, und dieses Problem wird ja nicht kleiner über die Zeit, sondern eher größer. Was spricht dagegen, dann auch mal unglaublich viel Geld in Forschung für freie Software, freie Standards und so weiter da mal reinzustecken, damit Leute auch damit arbeiten können? Also es gibt ja schon Projekte, die versuchen, dezentrale Netzwerke zu machen. Es gibt auch Projekte wie beispielsweise Friendlycar. Das ist ein alternatives soziales Netzwerk. Da sitzt jemand, der macht sich unglaublich viel Arbeit, immer wieder ein kleines Hintertürchen nach Facebook reinzubekommen, damit man zumindest rein und raus posten kann. Und der kriegt seinen Weg immer wieder verbaut. Und das macht Facebook absichtlich, weil Facebook natürlich überhaupt gar keinen Interesse an Interoperabilität hat. Und deshalb bräuchte es da auch eine gesetzliche Vorgabe, weil freiwillig wären die das nicht machen.
Genau, das ist eine Frage des politischen Willens. Das eine ist vielleicht auch große Anbieter dazu zu verpflichten. Das andere ist selber auch, also der Staat fördert ja Forschung beispielsweise. Die EU hat fette Forschungsprogramme Horizon 2020, wo extrem viel Geld in Technologieforschung geht. Auch die Bundesregierung gibt ja Start-up-Förderung und so weiter. Nur ist das bislang halt überhaupt nicht an Kriterien gebunden. Was wollen wir eigentlich? Was für Innovationen wollen wir? Was für Start-ups oder was für Technologie wollen wir eigentlich entwickeln? An welche Werte soll das gebunden sein? Ich glaube, da gäbe es schon Mittel und Wege, das viel stärker voranzutreiben, wenn dann der politische Wille da wäre.
Das Grundproblem, was man hier hat, ist, dass man halt, egal wie man es dreht und wenn, selbst wenn man jetzt sagt, man macht ein staatliches oder ein öffentlich-rechtliches oder ein Vereinsnetzwerk, durch diesen Netzwerkeffekt läuft es, gibt es immer eine Eigendynamik oder einen Anreiz, dass es immer wieder an den Punkt kommt, wo ein einzelner Anbieter einfach auf, sage ich mal, den Markt kontrolliert oder die meisten Nutzer hat. Und wo diese Machtasymetrie da ist, dann verfühlt es natürlich total dazu, das auszunutzen, ob es jetzt aus kommerziellen oder politischen Gründen ist. Und ja, dieses Problem, der also die Zentralität an sich oder diese Machtasymetrie ist, ja, das grundlegende Problem.
Das hört sich trotzdem so ein bisschen frustrierend an, weil die Frage ist natürlich, wie ist das umsetzbar? Gibt es irgendwas, die Positivbeispiele?
Ja, also es ist eigentlich gar nicht frustrierend, weil man sieht ja, dass es alternative soziale Netzwerke gibt. Es gibt auch eine sehr aktive Entwickler-Community, die sich damit beschäftigt. Und es gibt da auch immer wieder, sag ich mal, Neuentwicklungen oder neue Versuche und Lernerfolge. Und ich finde, das ist total super zu sehen, dass es eben, obwohl der Staat bis jetzt da unglaublich gepennt hat, in ordentlicher Weise Förderung rauszugeben, trotzdem Leute sagen, ja, ich denke, das ist der richtige Weg und diesen richtigen Weg müssen wir gehen. Und vielleicht braucht es auch alles auf einmal. Vielleicht, sag ich mal, in die richtige Richtung forschen, gleichzeitig gucken, ob man gemeinsame Standards macht und gleichzeitig noch die Datenschutzverstöße richtig teuer zu machen. Und gleichzeitig zu sagen, na ja, wir müssen Unternehmen einfach grundsätzlich verbieten, bestimmte Daten überhaupt zu verwerten.
Und bei Messengern gibt es, finde ich, positive Beispiele. Also Messenger ist ja so ein anderes Ding. Da gibt es ja inzwischen gute Alternativen zu WhatsApp. Es gäbe keinen Grund mehr, bei WhatsApp zu hängen eigentlich. Auch da wieder die Frage nach der Netzwerkeffekt. Auch da wieder die Frage nach der Interoperabilität. Es gibt sehr gute Alternativen.
Naja, aber da ist tatsächlich der Punkt, da müssen wir auch noch mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Aber es gibt ja keinen, also meiner Meinung nach oder meinem Empfinden nach, keinen einzigen Messenger, der perfekt ist.
Ja, aber das gilt vor allem für Dienste und Produkte.
Das gilt, naja, aber die Frage zu sagen, du hast halt dieses eine Medium, wo alle sind und dann sagst du ja komm mal darüber. Ich hab das einmal gemacht mit einem Messenger und ich kann das jetzt in meiner Filterbabel vielleicht noch ein, also Lifetime gesprochen, in meiner Lebenszeit kann ich noch einmal meiner Family sagen, wechselt bitte den Messenger. Es gibt momentan keinen, den ich empfehlen würde.
Was stört dich an Signal?
An Signal stört mich, dass das verpflichtend das Telefonbuch hochlädt. Du findest immer eine Sache, die sozusagen, die nicht ein kleines Ding ist, sondern die wirklich relevant, störend ist. Und deswegen, weiß ich nicht so genau, eine Frage, die wir auch noch gar nicht gesprochen haben, ist ja tatsächlich zu sagen, also dieses Ding, ich nehme Leute mit, ob das nicht schon fast eine Spur zu weit ist, weil davor das Problem ist ja, dass man überhaupt ein Bewusstsein dafür entwickelt, dass man auch so, dass man gar nicht auftauchen will. Ich kenne dieses Problem, ich mache ein Foto und ich stelle das natürlich online. Kennt ihr das auch?
Ja, also es ist natürlich immer so eine soziale Drucksituation. Also wenn, also ich sage immer ganz bewusst, hey Leute, grundsätzlich, wenn ihr Fotos macht, bitte fragt mich vorher. Also ja, das ist in manchen Kontexten auch schon keine Selbstverständlichkeit. Und wenn ihr das auf Facebook stellen wollt, dann sagt mir bitte Bescheid, weil dann gehe ich aus dem Bild. Und das mache ich nicht, weil ich euch nicht mag. Ganz im Gegenteil. Die Sachen, die mir ganz besonders viel bedeuten, die möchte ich nicht auf Facebook posten. Und wenn man das den Leuten so erklärt, dann verstehen sie es auch. Aber trotzdem gibt es eben diese sozialen Drucksituationen. Als ich studiert hab, wollte mein Jahrgang, die Altklausuren auf Facebook in der Gruppe tauschen. Und ja, da war ich, die nicht auf Facebook war damals, und ein Freund von mir, und wir haben zusammen dann dafür lobbyiert, bitte ein alternatives Netzwerk zu nutzen, was ich dann aufgesetzt hab. Und das hat auch funktioniert. Also meine Erfahrung ist, es macht Sinn im Familien- und Freundeskreis, einfach mal drüber zu sprechen, ist vielleicht auch ein anderes, also ein ganz angenehmes Thema für den Rostertisch im Vergleich zu anderen Themen. Und ja, also ich glaube, Menschen denken auch zunehmend differenzierter darüber. Je länger man das auch selbst nutzt, je mehr Datenskandale.
Also warte mal, heißt das sozusagen, also man ist halt jemand, der sich schon seit Jahrzehnten gefühlt mit dem Thema Beschäftigte oder Umständen viel frustrierter. Also sozusagen, man bricht jetzt ab, hat keinen Bock mehr. Aber dabei ist jetzt vielleicht doch die Zeit gekommen, wo alle anfangen, drüber nachzudenken.
Ja klar.
Ich glaube schon, dass das gesellschaftliche Bewusstsein für das Thema auf jeden Fall wächst. Mit jedem Skandal sozusagen wird es deutlicher. Das ist ja auch das, dass ich, wenn ich hier so einen blöden Persönlichkeitstest mit einer Facebook-App mache, dass das dann die Daten von mir und von meinen Freunden sammelt und ich auf dieser Grundlage dann später politische Botschaften zugeschnitten bekomme. Diesen gedanklichen Schritt, den muss man ja erstmal nachvollziehen können. Und ich glaube, da kommen wir als Gesellschaft hin. Für mich ist dann aber wieder die Frage, ich finde es okay, das auf einer individuellen Ebene irgendwie zu diskutieren, Freunde zu überzeugen usw. Ich glaube aber, es ist einfach ein gesellschaftliches Problem, für das wir politische Lösungen brauchen. Und ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen, es fehlt da einfach bislang am politischen Willen, das auch anders zu gestalten. Ich finde es gerade beim Thema Datenschutz, auf EU-Ebene wird gerade die E-Privacy-Verordnung verhandelt, wo es darum ginge, Nutzerinnen und Nutzern zu erleichtern, sich gegen Third-Party-Tracking zu wehren. Dass der Do-Not-Track-Standard oder etwas Ähnliches beispielsweise verpflichtend wäre. Eine unfassbare Lobby-Kampagne, die sich dagegen wehrt und die eben ziemlich erfolgreich ist dabei, die Politik davon zu überzeugen, dass es eine schlechte Idee ist, dass es das Internet letztendlich kaputt macht, wenn Nutzerinnen und Nutzer selbst darüber entscheiden können, ob sie durch ihre Bewegung durchs Web verfolgt werden wollen oder nicht und ob auf dieser Grundlage in Werbung zugespielt werden soll. Also ePrivacy-Verordnung an der Stelle kann ich nicht oft genug sagen, ist der Datenschutz-Battle, der gerade stattfindet, leider ziemlich unterm Radar, wo es im EU-Parlament eine echt gute Positionierung gab, wo trotz eines harten Widerstands der Konservativen es gelungen ist, an der Stelle eine starke...
Jetzt muss ich aber leider sagen, du sagst so ganz am Ende der Sendung, wo wir keine Zeit mehr haben, ein neues Fass aufgemacht, was wir nicht mal noch genauer erläutert kriegen. Möglicherweise wird das dann ein Thema einer der kommenden Sendungen. Eine Datenschutzgrundverordnung ist jetzt gerade und dann später kommt die E-Barris-Richtlinie. Aber wir können mal festhalten, auf der persönlichen Ebene nochmal, liebe Nerds, gebt nicht auf. Liebe Nicht-Nerds, wenn euch die Nerds erklären, warum gewisse Dinge vielleicht noch bedenkenswert sind, wollen sie euch nicht den Spaß verderben, sondern haben Interesse daran, dass das Leben möglichst gut bleibt. Das haben wir in den letzten zwei Stunden auch versucht. Hoffen, dass es gelungen ist und freuen uns über Kommentare unter chaosradio.ccc.de Vielen Dank Katascha und Ingo, dass ihr hier wart. Wo kann man euch das nächste Mal sehen, lesen, hören, was auch immer?
Ja, also am 27. April, da erscheint so ein Buch von mir. Ich unter anderem mein Facebook Trauma verarbeite, aber auch diverse Traumata mit Polizeidatenbanken. Und mein Daten und ja, es heißt die Daten, die ich rief. Und ihr könnt das, wenn euch interessiert, gerne lesen.
Mich kann man regelmäßig auf netzpolitik.org lesen. Unter anderem viel zu Facebook, WhatsApp, Cambridge Analytica in der letzten Zeit, aber auch zu anderen Themen, wo es um Digital Rights sozusagen geht, das größere Feld, vor allen Dingen im Bereich Daten und das nächste Mal erleben am kommenden Dienstag in der Seabase hier in Berlin beim Netzpolitischen Abend der digitalen Gesellschaft, Thema Dateneigentum und Datenökonomie, ein Themenabend der digitalen Gesellschaft zu diesem Thema. Ich kann nur empfehlen, da vorbeizukommen.
Dann vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart, dass ihr mit uns alles geteilt und so geduldig erklärt habt. Vor allem sehr gerne. Und im Hintergrund, man kann das ja auch sehen, zum Beispiel dieses Chaosradio, haben Mo und Dani Mo heute dafür gesorgt, dass die Technik überall stattfindet und haben außerdem noch ein paar Veranstaltungstipps für euch. Ja, zum einen die Mesh-Syndere. Das ist also eine Veranstaltung zu Wi-Fi und Mesh-Netzwerken. Mesh-Netzwerke, das sind die Dinger, wo man drahtlos versucht, Strecken zu überwinden. Mit Vortragsprogramm und Workshop vom 7. bis zum 13. Mai. Mehr gibt es auf www.wirelessmeshup.org. Und ganz aktuell das Easter Hack, das geht morgen los. Und ist ein sehr schönes CCC-Treffen, nicht ganz so groß wie der Kongress, aber auch Vortragsprogramme. Und die könnt ihr euch live auch angucken unter eh18.easterhackhegg.eu. Auf jeden Fall. Gut, dann vielen Dank. Dann bleibt mir nur noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich wünsche euch, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network, Biat.